[Musique]
Marc andevel bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle servview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement donc je m'appelle Marc
andevel je suis journaliste j'ai 43 ans
j'ai travaillé pour différents journaux
notamment témoignage chrétien la tribune
journal
économique j'ai travaillé à plusieurs
reprises pour Marianne notamment la
précédente année et j'ai je viens de
quitter l'ebdomadaire j'ai pris ce qu'on
appelle une la clause de conscience
parce que
j'étais sceptique quant à l'évolution du
titre et notamment sur le fait qu'on a
qu'on m'a notifié nous a
notifier participant de la cellule
enquête du journal que l'Invest ation
n'était plus la priorité du journal et
que la cellule enquête on a appris sa
suppression par voix de presse dans un
article de la lettre A début janvier ce
soir on va parler République les
affaires quelques petites peut-être les
oligarques je ne sais pas plein de
choses on commence par quoi bah
peut-être les raisons encore de mon
départ de Marianne et le
journalisme là-dessus et et on adore les
journalistes d'investigation qui font
bien leur travail et et on a beaucoup de
respect pour vous qu'est-ce qui se passe
à
Marienne
bah il y a eu toute une une année un peu
compliquée où donc l'actionnaire de
référence de enfin l'actionnaire de
Marianne Daniel
kretinski qui est un milliardaire tchque
notamment dans
l'énergie le charbon et notamment qui
est propriétaire d'une société qui a
également la propriété d'un d'un
pipeline d'un gazoduc qui passe par la
Slovaquie et puis par l'Ukraine jusqu'à
la Russie euh et bien sa filiale média
qui s'appelle CMI en
France a décidé dans un premier temps de
vendre le titre ça a été annoncé en mars
dernier mars de l'année dernière
euh donc moi je venais juste d'être
réembauché parce que j'avais déjà quitté
le magazine en
2018 au moment de l'arrivée d'ailleurs
de Daniel kretinski
kretinski ou kretinski je ne sais pas
kretinski kretinski euh plutôt kretinski
je crois
et et donc en 2018 j'ai j'avais donc
bénéficié de la clause de session après
je vais revenir sur ces terme par la
suite mais donc en 2018 j'avais fait
l'analyse que mon travail d'enquête ne
pouvait plus se continuer euh on va dire
dans un cadre euh confortable et soutenu
dans dans le journal c'est le moment où
Natacha Poloni est nommée par Daniel
kretinski à
l'époque parce que très tôt j'avais
compris en 2018 que Daniel
kretinski était
proche de l'Élysée de l'Élysée ou de
Macron de de de l'Élysée de l'écosystème
du pouvoir autour du du château comme
les journalistes politiques le
présentent à travers un travail de
lobbying depuis assez longtemps depuis
2017 2018 il y a des traces de ça ah bah
des traces oui une trace une trace qui
date je crois de
2023 ou 2022 Daniel kretinski s'est
retrouvé invité à l'Élysée juste à côté
de Brigit Macron donc le lobbing a
fonctionné d'une certaine manière et
puis il faut se rappeler qu'en 2018-29
il y avait les grands projet que j'ai en
partie dévoilé dans mon dans mon livre
le grand manipulateur qui concerne les
réseaux d'Emmanuel Macron je dévoilais
ce qu'on appel ce qu'on a appelé par la
suite le plan Hercule c'est-à-dire le la
réorganisation le démantellement de DF
euh et c'est aussi dans ce cadre-là que
potentiellement beaucoup de gens se
posaient des questions sur les ambitions
énergétique de Daniel krtinski en France
et j'en ai fait état dans deux chapitres
du grand manipulateur donc qui a été
publié en avril 2019 un chapitre qui
s'appelle Big Bang de l'énergie où je
parle autant de du projet hercul de DF
que que l'avenir de d'engj
ou de Total en sachant qu'Emmanuel
Macron depuis très longtemps considère
qu'on a trop de champions dans ce
domaine là et qu'il font donc faire des
des
fusions ce qui d'ailleurs sur le
principe peut se
discuterin mais effectivement dans ce
cadre
là il y a eu il y a eu des discussions
don dont je fais état d'ailleurs dans
dans mon livre dans de 2019 Daniel
kretinski a investi a racheté deux
centrales à charbon euh de DF dans le
sud de la France et je sais plus où
d'ailleurs euh toujours en activité en
partie alors que la loi prévoit la
fermeture des centrales charbon mais ça
ça fait partie d'un des modèles
économiques de Danel ktinski euh et puis
il y a un autre chapitre du grand
manipulateur qui s'appelle média en
stress où j'évoquais déjà les les
ambitions dans les médias de Daniel
kretinski parce que à l'époque en 2018
après avoir acheté
Marianne donc ça ça s'est déroulé entre
avril
et août 2018 moi je suis parti fin août
2018 du
magazine et bien il a racheté les
activités une partie des activités de
presse qui restait du groupe lagardire
notamment elle journal emblématique mais
également de la press
people et puis il a surtout il a
débarqué sans vraiment prévenir dans
dans la d'une manière indirecte mais
dans l'actionnariat du monde ce qui a
provoqué la fureur de de Xavier Niel à
l'époque et donc ça c'est pour replacer
le contexte de l'époque en 2018 et 2019
et et donc moi après après le grand
manipulateur j'ai rejoint comme
collaborateur régulier comme pigiste
régulier j'ai rejoint le journal
économique La Tribune pour faire des
chroniques politiques mais également
économiques et faire des enquêtes donc
ça j'ai fait ça jusqu'en 2023 où rodolp
Saad donc propriétaire de CMA CGM grand
armateur Franco libanais a décidé
d'investir dans la tribune et de lancer
la tribune dimanche l'
hebbdomadaire du dimanche euh là mon
travail a fait que j'ai pas été associé
au lancement de la de la tribune
dimanche et à ce moment-là Natacha
Poloni donc que je connaissais très peu
avec qui j'avais pas travaillé euh
m'a relancé m'a reproposé de parce
qu'elle me l'avait déjà fait dans par le
passé de revenir au journal pour faire
des enquêtes dans le cadre d'une cellule
enquête donc ce qu'on appelle
communément l'investigation bon ça c'est
un grand terme un peu fouretour on
pourra peut-être revenir derrière
qu'est-ce que ça signifieontologie aussi
voilà
euh et donc je suis revenu au journal
dans un premier temps par des piges
régulières en décembre 2023 et et par un
CDI en février 2022 ça c'est le euh
février 2024 et donc bon ça c'est le
calendrier
en au bout d'une semaine était annoncé
la réduction de 40 pages du magazine euh
bon on m'avait pas prévenu et puis euh
et puis quelques semaines après on a
appris la vente du journal donc ça ça ça
ça a ouvert une période de 9 mois un peu
compliquée euh qui a abouti finalement
un changement de décision de la part de
l'actionnaire parce que il a finalement
décidé de ne plus
vendre il a annoncé ça à la rédaction en
décembre et dans le même temps Natacha
Poloni
euh on va
dire a été remplacé remplacé par
Frédéric
tadi bon à la manœuvre le président de
Sami en France et Denis Oliven homme
d'affair qui travaill avec le groupe la
garder euh et puis durant toute cette
période là bon ça a été volaté dans la
presse hein il y a eu une tentative de
rachat du journal par milliardaire
versaillais plutôt très à droite qui
s'appelle Pierre-Edouard STERIN donc
finalement la rédaction s'y est opposée
c'était un avis consultatif mais de
toute façon les négociations ont pas
abouti puis il y a eu d'autres
tentatives de rachat qu'on pas qu'on pas
abouti et puis et donc en
décembre a été annoncé les les les
grandes orientations suivantes du
journal et donc on a compris on a
compris que sur le plan éditorial il y
aurait des changement d'ailleurs ça a
été annoncé comme ça hein ça a été
annoncé comme ça et donc ça a été relaté
dans une tribune des journalistes de
Marianne parce que je suis pas tout seul
à m'avoir posé beaucoup de questions
dans le rapport à l'actionnaire aux
actionnaires à d'éventuel repreneur à la
question de
l'indépendance journalistique euh
la rédaction s'est réunie nombreuses
reprises pendant plus de 9 mois pour
pour discuter de ça dans des assemblées
générales et puis fin décembre
2000 2024 donc quand Denis Oliven est
venu au journal donc ça ça a été relaté
notamment dans une tribune des
journalistes de Marianne qui a été
publiée dans le
monde et bien il a il a il a souhaité
que le journal soit plus business
friendly c'est les termes qui ont été
publiés dans le monde et puis également
qu'on s'attaque moins à tous les
pouvoirs et ça ça a été verbalisé c'est
ça a été la rédaction l'a écouté et donc
la rédaction collectivement l'a publié
dans le monde dans une tribune et
effectivement les choses ont été dites
de cette
manière-là à ce moment-là d'ailleurs
Denia Oliven nous a expliqué que si on
était pas content avec ça si on était
pas d'accord on pouvait prendre sa
clause de conscience donc je vais
revenir sur le dispositif et que pour
pour les
profils plus jeunes ou avec le moins
d'ancienneté comme
moi il donnait quelques mois d'indemnité
supplémentair pas beaucoup en
réalité pour susciter un départ plus
massif et donc quand
même la fin février on a appris que
quand même 18 journalistes de Marianne
avait décidé de partir 18 journalistes
sur
39 postes internes 50 cartes de presse
en tout mais en comptabilisant également
les pigistes réguliers donc 18
journalistes sur 39 postes interne ça
signifie quand même beaucoup de
choses les gens qui faisaient de
l'enquête bah il y a des gens qu' qu'
ont décidé d'arrester mais d'autres qui
ont décidé de partir donc il y a une
consœur son nom a été cité dans la
lettre A qui s'appelle Vanessa Ratinier
qui a décidé de de
partir le responsable de la cellule
enquête qui était directeur adjoint de
la rédaction Gérald d'riilleux a décidé
également de partir hier et puis
d'autres journalistes de de l'équipe
dont les noms ont pas encore été évoqués
donc je vais pas les je vais pas encore
les citer
mais mais ils le feront deux même mais
ces journalistes pouvaient être soit
travailler sur la police justice sur la
macronie donc sur c'est des gens qui
faisaient un travail d'information au
sein du journal euh c'est pas comme ça
Puut être caricaturé des gens qui
avaient une ligne éditoriale très marqué
pour certains au contraire non c'était
des gens des journalistes qui
produisaient beaucoup d'articles il
suffisait de lire le l le le magazine et
euh c'est des gens qu'on considéré qu'il
pouvaient plus continuer à faire leur
travail dans de bonnes conditions je
peux me faire l'avocat du
diable on a un investisseur euh qui fait
du business qui se positionne sur des
secteurs porteurs comme l'énergie qui
anticipe des tendances du fait que la
transition charbon énergie renouvelable
ça risque d'être compliqué il décide de
faire de la philanthropie ou d'investir
dans un journal et et la question que je
vous pose c'est est-ce que le journal
était à l'équilibre budgétairement
parlant non comme tous les journaux t
les tous les journaux perdent de
l'argent perdre de l'argent ça on va
revenir dessus tous les journaux perdent
de l'argent après il y a des manières de
présenter les choses voilà donc et donc
donc il y a des manières de présenter
les choses euh ça n'a pas été présenté
comme un plan économie les décisions qui
ont été prises même si des économies ont
déjà été faites
euh le journal perd de l'argent comme
toute la presse en même temps
euh Marianne est un était j'allais dire
ça on pourra peut-être revenir dessus
mais faisait partie du marché de des
news mag news magazine et en diffusion
kiosque vente payée en kiosk Marianne
rivalisait quasiment avec le point
pointnonadire de droite bien
installé largement au-dessus de des
diffusion payée
d'une d'autres news magazines comme je
sais pas comme par
exempleexpress on est quand même sur
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
diffusion payée kiosque papier de la
presse française c'est écroulé depuis
déjà une vingtaine d'années mais il y a
eu une accélération depuis 5 ans
parce que globalement sur le marché des
news
mag en vente
payé pas pas ce qu'on appelle diffusion
parce que diffusion c'est plus large
mais en en vente payée on est sur une
division par 2 en 5 ans sur l'ensemble
des titres quasiment et dans ce cadre là
Marianne résistait un peu mieux que
d'autres concurrents
euh donc ça faisait dire à à d'éventuels
investisseurs ou à des gens en interne
d'ailleurs que le le journal a des
potentialités économiques en si en fait
en réalité encore encore là la la
faiblesse du magazine était plus liée au
site internet où il y avait où il y a
moins d'abonnés numériques que d'autres
d'autres titres mais là aussi par
rapport au concurrence c'est pas
dramatique
euh concernant Internet la concurrence
vient plutôt du du du monde euh avec
400000 abonnés numériques c'est
considérable c'est premier média euh sur
Internet miaap 200000 abonnés numériques
euh et donc ça on a tendance à l'oublier
mais la la bascule presse papier
numérique euh fait que il y a des titres
qui s'en sont bien sortis qui soi
spécialisés pur player comme on dit
comme méiapart ou d'autres titres au
contraire historiquement dans la presse
écrite euh mais des d'autres titres de
presse écrit son sont moins bien tirés
ça c'est clair et donc je termine ma
pldoirie euh euh quand il dit
l'expression c'est business friendly ou
j'ai pas compris c'est euh business
enfin c'est ce qui a été publié he
business friendly et il faut il faut
arrêter de de de chercher des ennuis à
tous les pouvoirs en fait voilà
systématiquement systématiquement voilà
quelle a été la perception des
journalistes qui travaillaient là-bas il
s'est dit voilà c'est un investisseur
qui est Macron compatible ou c'est un
investisseur qui a décidé de porter le
business qu'on arrête d'embêter les
entrepreneurs les milliardaires et ceux
qui font du blé pour le
pays je comprends pas la question la
question c'est est-ce que ceux qui
investissent dans la presse on une ligne
éditoriale est-ce qu'ils influencent
réellement les lignes éditoriales des
des canards quand on entend le oui
enfin il y a des journaux qui sont des
institutions
comme comme le monde euh
ù le groupe le monde et le monde le
monde groupe Le Monde c'est plus
important mais le monde c'est entre 400
et 500 journalistes donc c'est une
énorme collectivité euh là Mariane c'est
un tout petit bateau en fait avec très
très peu de journalistes c'est artisanal
ça reste artisanal dans la fabrication
euh et donc bien évidemment il y a
beaucoup moins de tampon entre
l'actionnaire et la chaîne hiérarchique
parce que et le journaliste parce qu'en
fait il y a beaucoup moins d'échelons et
ces tampons sont parfois utiles euh y
compris en terme de de contrepouvoir et
euh de de et justement de préservation
d'un cadre d'indépendance donc tacha
Polonie l'a fait ça quand j'y étais j'ai
publié tous les articles que que je
souhaitais et que que en accord avec la
la direction de la rédaction oui
euh j'ai fait quand même quelques
articles je peux en citer certains j'ai
fait des articles sur l'affaire colère
où j'ai euh publié en exclusivité des
des échanges de mails qui n'apparaissent
pas dans le dossier d'instruction de
l'affaire colère mais qui concerne la
période quand Alexis coller était
directeur adjoint de cabinet de Pierre
Moscovici entre 2012 et 2014 sous le
quinquen Hollande échange de mail qui
montre que contrairement aux
déclarations des défenseurs d'Alexis
Caire ou d'Alexis ca lui-même il n'y a
pas eu de déport effectif donc un déport
euh signifie le fait de donc de ne pas
traiter d'un dossier de ne pas être
comment dire de ne pas recevoir de notes
de de ne pas être décisionnaire ou ou en
tout cas intégré d'une manière ou d'une
autre à des décisions relatives à un
dossier euh en l'occurrence le dossier
MSC et MSC STX MSC étant le plus grand
armateur mondial et istx étant le
chantier exchantier de de l'ATL tique
chantier construction navale à
saint-nazer et MSC était le premier
client de
STX et l'État français ces dernières
années a garanti des prêts pour la vente
de pagbo de STX pour
l'activité enfin loisir et pagbo de MSC
parce que MSC c'est un grand
transporteur mondial comme armateur mais
ils ont également une filiale qui
s'appelle MSC croisière et dans ce
cadre-là ce qu'on appelle l'affaire
colère je le rappelle c'est le fait que
dans ces différentes fonctions au sein
de l'État tant pour Bery quand il était
au service de Bercy notamment rattaché à
l'agence de participation de
l'État et puis ensuite comme conseiller
dans les cabinets ministériels donc de
Moscovici et d'Emmanuel Macron entre
2014 et 2016 euh et bien dans toutes ses
fonctions Alexis CER n'a n'a pas
organisé de déport effectif n'a pas
suffisamment euh explicité le son lien
familial c'est c'est votre avis son lien
non c'est la vie de la justice c'est la
vie de la justice je vais expliquer ça
juste après mais donc Alexis Caire n'a
pas explicité son lien familial
euh au sein des équipes par des notes
par exemple ce qui pouvait être fait
dans d'autres cabinets d'ailleurs
l'enquête l'a montré et donc son lien
familial avec la famille propriétaire de
MSC la famille aponé en l'occurrence
c'est la mère d'Alexis CER qui s'appelle
l'origine sola Hakim qui est cousine
germaine de
rafhaella
apponé qui est la com dire la condatrice
avec son mari jean-luigi aponé de du
groupe
MSC l'enquête a montré par ailleurs que
des liens familiaux relatif ement poussé
parce que la famille d'Alexis ca ses
enfants son épouse ont a plusieurs étés
plusieurs reprises à différents étés sur
le Yach de la famille
àoné accueilli durant plusieurs semaines
ça c'est ce que les les enquêteurs ont
découvert et donc dans le cadre de cette
enquête he qui a eu énormément de
rebondissement depuis 2018 et les
révélations de Mia part au départ parce
que c'est une révélation de presse à
l'origine qui est à l'origine de de
l'affaire judiciaire en cas de
préliminaire puis ensuite ouverture
d'une information judiciaire c'estd la
nomination de juge d'instruction suite à
la plainte en partie civile de
l'association antiorps de l'association
antiorps donc l'association de lutte
contre la
corruption et et donc effectivement pour
revenir à la
question la défense d'Alexis CER et dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu de d'actes positif de
dissim tion ça c'est les termes
juridiques qui ont été utilisés mais en
réalité la justice n'est pas
d'accord tant le juge d'instruction
enfin les juges d'instruction que
aujourd'hui la cour d'appel parce que
dans le cadre d'un
recours de des défenseurs d'Alexis CER
auprès de la chambre d'instruction de la
cour d'appel de
Paris sur qui concernait la prescription
de fait avant 2004 14 donc justement au
niveau de ces activités au cabinet de
moscovis comme les activités précédentes
euh le recours voulait que la justice
considère que ces faitsl soi prescrit
donc ne puisse plus faire l'objet de de
poursuite judiciaire voire
potentiellement d'être envoyé au procès
et et donc la cour d'appel a après avoir
été comment dire enfin il y a eu d'abord
un arrêt enfin un arrêt une décision
rendu par juge d'instruction qui
considéré que le recours
était pas concluant ça a été renvoyé
donc à la
Chambre d'appel enfin la chambre
d'instruction de la cour d'appel de
Paris qui finalement fin novembre a
expliqué très exactement qu'on était
pour reprendre les termes des juges
d'instruction qu'on était face à un
pacte du silence les mots sont forts
reinitier bon très concrètement ça veut
dire
que la justice considère que si Alexis
ca a
pu ponctuellement expliciter son lien
familial avec la famille propriétaire de
MSC à certains de ses collègues ou à
certains de ses
chefs ça il y a sa hiérarchie directe ou
certains de ses collègues n'ont jamais
informé le reste de la collectivité ni
au sein des cabinets ni même au sein de
l'administration de Bercy Emmanuel
Macron est au courant ou pas c'est ce
qu'il a c'est ce qu'il a expliqué Macron
comme président de la République en en
juin 2019 mai juin 2019 ou juillet je
sais plus exactement les dates
euh cas relativement unique je pense
dans un dossier judiciaire comme
président de la République dans un
courrier sans enentête de sans enentête
de l'Élysée a signé un courrier
manuscrit pour expliquer que Alexis CER
ne lui avait jamais caché son lien
familial avec le groupe MSC que bien
évidemment il y avait eu un déport
organisé au sein de son cabinet
euh et également à ce moment-là en juin
juuillet 2019
d'autres anciens collègues ont pu faire
les mêmes genres de courriers d'autres
Haut- fonctionnaires de ber on peut
faire le même genre de courrier ça ça a
été apporté par la défense d'Alexis CER
à ce moment-là je reviendrai sur l'été
2019 il s'est passé plusieurs événements
assez importants euh mais donc pour
revenir à la décision de la Cour d'appel
elle est quand même relativement
importante parce que c'est une décision
qui fait plus de 30 pages ou que j'ai lu
comme d'autres
journalistes cette décision revient sur
l'ensemble du dossier
et en retraçant la chronologie du
dossier l'effet récupérés par les
enquêteurs et en fait tout cela
démontre enfin en tout cas démontre en
tout cas pour la justice pour l'instant
on verra sil a renvoie au procès
l'instruction est continue hein et en
coursés d'inoc tout à fait présomption
d'innocence mais en tout cas pour cette
manchel judiciaire euh les la cour
d'appel n'a pas du tout suivi les
conclusions de la défense de des
défenseurs de d'Alexis CER alors même
que je précise en octobre dernier euh le
parquet euh n'avait pas suivi juge
d'instruction mais avait été dans le
sens des défenseurs d'Alexis ca euh ce
qui était normalement un avantage euh
mais ça veut dire que le parquet
euh avait décidé de en fait de que la
prescription était acquise et donc
allait dans le sens de des défenseurs
sculaire je me répète je suis désolé
euh et la cour d'appel a à apportter un
on va dire un un avis particulièrement
négatif à cette à ce rapport là au
dossier si on veut dire si on va dire si
on peut dire et euh et dans les 30 pages
c'est assez édifiant parce que
effectivement euh les les 30 pages
racontent réellement très précisément
euh peut-être une certaine vision du
dossier mais qui en tout cas pas la
vision du dossier des défenseurs
d'Alexis ca ni même la vision d'Alexis
de CA sur le dossier et donc pour
revenir à à mon article publié fin
octobre d'abord sur le site internet de
Marianne puis dans le cadre d'une
couverture euh du magazine en début
octobre euh j'ai dit fin octobre fin
septembre je sais plus donc fin
septembre pour les articles Internet et
début octobre pour la pour le dossier en
couverture
euh j'ai publié des des mails auxquels
j'ai eu accès qui n'étaient pas
vraisemblablement dans le dans le
dossier d'instruction et qui démontre
encore un peu plus par rapport aux
pièces judiciaires déjà récupérées par
les enquêteurs qui démontrre encore un
peu plus queil n'y avait pas de déport
effectif en tout cas au moment du
cabinet Moscovici et qu'en plus à
l'époque
euh il y avait une enquête en fait menée
par la Commission
européenne lancée sur la question des
garanties apporté par l'état français
justement sur les les les financements
euh de des projets de pagbo STX euh et
au nom des règles de la concurrence he
qu'on connaît à
Bruxelles il s'agissait de vérifier si
euh il n'y avait pas de
trop de subventions qui pouvaent
justifier le la signature de contrat
entre STX et
des là pour le coup des des grands
professionnels de la croisière donc en
l'occurrence MSC mais
l'enquête se penchait pas sur MSC mais
se penchait sur le concurrent de
MSC la Royal Caribbean
Company qui est également l'autre client
de STX et là on a aperçu que tout le
dossier du côté administratif et du
cabinet Moscovici il s'agissait pour
l'état de savoir comment financer ses
grands contrats à une époque où STX
avait des difficultés économiques fortes
donc il y avait une pression sur
l'emploi qui était forte je rappelle à
l'époque le que le premier ministre
était Jean-Marc
herraud maire de Nant historiquement
socialiste et que donc le le Premier
ministre gardait ça comme la sur le feu
euh et d'ailleurs ça on le voit dans les
mails échanger effectivement euh et on
voit Alexis coller s'intéresser voir
parfois donner des avis sur le
financement euh des projets STX mais qui
dans le même temps concerne à MSC parce
que sur cette même période MSC était en
négociation directe avec STX pour la
construction de de paquebau euh et bien
sur cette périodel euh enquête de la
Commission européenne manifestement euh
en tout cas dans les éléments que j'ai
recueillis la Commission européenne ne
connaissait pas non plus le lien
familial entre Alexis ca et la famille
àonté parce que ça restait pour
reprendre les termes qui ont été écrits
par les juges d'instruction et confirmé
d'une certaine manière repris par la
cour d'appel de Paris euh donc on parle
d'un pacte de du silence
entreinitier les mots sont forts
euh et je rappelle
reprendre les terminologies juridiques
que pour l'instant Alexis colaire est
mise en examen pour prise illégale
d'intérêt donc en
fait de la présomption d'innocence oui
mais donc en réalité prise illégale
d'intérêt ça signifie le fait de pas
avoir
déclaré mis en place et mis en place un
dispositif on va dire de sécurité par
rapport à un conflit d'intérêt manifeste
c'est des choses très classiqu en fait
enfin très classique notamment dans la
grande entreprise ou dans des pay pays
plus libéraux économiquement notamment
aux États-Unis au Royaume-Uni on va dire
c'est des dispositifs qui sont
régulièrement mise en
place bon peut-être que la France enfin
la France normalement doit aussi faire
enfin fait des efforts dans le domaine
mais ce qui est très intéressant dans le
dossier colaire
euh pourra aussi avoir lu des des
auditions de haut fonctionnaires
ou de de de consiller dans les cabinets
c'est
l'incompréhension de ces grands esprits
on va dire qui ont été dans les plus
grandes écoles de la République devant
des questions très simples des des juges
ou des policiers euh c'estàdire en fait
ils ne ils ne veulent pas être ils ne
souhaitent pas ils ne comprennent pas
comment ils peuvent être mis en question
sur leur leur défaut de de respect des
règles en terme de d'établissement de
conflit d'intérêts ou enfin de de
préservation des conflits d'intérêts
dans le cadre de leur activités tu étais
peut-être pas au courant ah bah non là
le dossier là les les personnes
auxquelles je fais référence elles étent
pour le coup c'est le fameux pack du
silence et donc je rappelle d'ailleurs
qu'il y a deux haut fonctionnaires de
Bercy qui sont également mis en examen
en l'occurrence jean-dominque Comoli et
Brau bzard qui ont été
successivement patron de donc l'Agence
des participation de l'État euh
présomption d'innocence aussi ou colère
à l'époque enfin travaillait ça c'était
avant Moscovici et il avait été au
conseil d'administration de
STX et au conseil d'administration euh
du port du Havre voilà euh enfin du oui
conseil d'administration dans donc du
grand port du Havre
euh où le groupe MSC dispose de de
terminaux via sa filiale ce qu'on
appelle la filiale til de gestion de
port euh voilà là j'ai résumé en en peu
de mots une affaire
euh euh importante où les un dossier
important où les
les où les policiers ont énormément
travaillé où les juges ont énormément
travaillé
euh pour avoir connu d'autres dossiers
judiciaires de cet ordre là euh je
trouve que les que le travail est très
précis dans dans dans les actes
euh il y a pas
de il y a pas d'erreur euh dans dans
dans tout ce qu'ils ont entrepris et
pourtant ils ont eu des difficultés euh
des difficultés pour récupérer les
documents euh à ber pour récupérer les
documents à différents endroits et en
2019 parce que je le rappelais en 2019
euh
donc en juin 2019 la patronne du parquet
national
financier Elan Noulette part à la
retraite enfin en tout cas oui il y a
une vacance de pouvoir au PNF pendant 3
mois moi et à ce moment-là euh c'est le
moment où en fait il y a un rapport de
intermédiaire sur rapport des policiers
qui enquête sur le dossier
euh qui donnent leurs conclusions et en
fait Mia part a démontré que ce rapport
on leur avait demandé justement de le
réécrire après réception des différents
courriers notamment du courrier du
président de la République
euh et donc on peut comparer les de
deuxpp avant et après qui des rapports
qui n'ont strictement rien à voir disons
que le premier rapport allait on va dire
dans le sens des conclusion aujourd'hui
de juge d'instruction euh
ou de la cour d'appel le second rapport
n'allait pas dans le sens de ces
conclusions là et ce qui avait permis je
crois l'automne 2019 euh ou juste un an
après je sais plus là j'ai j'ai un trou
de mémoire au niveau des dates en tout
cas ce qui avait permis
euh au PNF de
décider la la l'arrêt des des poursuites
dans le cadre de l'enquête préliminaire
la fermeture de l'enquête préliminaire
et donc il a fallu ensuite que
anticorps monte au créneau à travers une
plainte en partie civile avec
constitution de parti civile ce qui a
relancé le dossier avec un juge
d'instruction vous connaissez Eric
cocrel euh oui enfin il a demandé
l'audition de de qui déjà ah oui dans
c'est vrai j'allais oublier
euh sur cette forme d'impunité si on
peut appeler ça impunité au sens quand
je j'expliquait la difficulté de ces au
fonctionnaires ces serviteurs de l'État
euh parfois de reconnaître leurs erreurs
parce que ça peut être tout simplement
des erreurs
euh effectivement euh donc Éric coochrel
qui est vice-président de la commission
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale si
je me trompe pas euh à dans le cadre
d'une commission d'enquête liée au
déficit enfin au dérapage des prévisions
du budgétaire français de l'année
dernière euh Eric CREL a demandé
l'audition de du secrétaire général de
l'Élysée Alexis coller et Alexis
cololler n'a pas souhaité s'y déplacer
euh et donc Éric coqurel continu ses
démarches pour essayer de faire venir et
faire respecter les droits du Parlement
à enquêter sur des dossiers relatifs à
la République et ça ça ça montre on se
souvient d'ailleurs la seule foi où
Alexis CER s'est dévoilé aux yeux du
grand public c'était en
2018 lors de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat
ou de l'Assemblée nationale j'ai un j'ai
un j'ai un doute euh non au Sénat c'est
ça au Sénat parce queà l'Assemblée
nationale la commission d'enquête a
s'est interrompu très rapidement au
sujet du dossier
benala là Alexis colaire c'est avait dû
et avait accepté on va dire de se
déplacer devant la comm commission
d'enquête des sénateurs sur le dossier
benala et on se souvient que devant les
caméras de télévision il n'était pas
très à l'aise ni très ravi d'être là lui
qu'on présente un peu comme l'homme de
l'ombre de l'Élysée l'éminence grise de
d'Emmanuel Macron et donc je rappelle un
secrétaire général de l'Élysée c'est
c'est quasiment la personne la plus
importante dans le dispositif élyséen
parce que après le président de la
République bien évidemment c'est son
principal collaborateur et c'est c'est
la la gare de triage comme il se
présente lui-même souvent c'est la tour
de contrôle du président de la
République au
regard à la fois des liens avec les
ministres et de l'ensemble de des
administrations de l'État donc c'est un
poste puissant d'autant plus puissant
qu'Alexis CER n'a jamais enfin Alexis
CER fait partie de donc de de de ces
grands fonctionnaires grands serviteurs
d'État quieven qui sont devenus
secrétaires généraux de l'Élysée euh
selon les dir de Jean-Pierre jouillet un
de ses prédécesseurs qui a été à ce
poste- là sous François Hollande dans la
2uxème partie du quinquena jouillet
considère que Alexis CER n'a jamais eu
autant enfin on n jamais vu un
secrétaire général avoir autant de
pouvoirs de toute la 5e République
c'est-à-dire que dans le dispositif de
pouvoir instauré par Emmanuel Macron une
hyper présidence extrêmement verticale y
compris dans le contrôle politique de
l'Élysée directement auprès des ministre
et du gouvernement il y a une
concentration du pouvoir à l'Élysée par
rapport à Matignon enfin plus maintenant
hein parce que maintenant avec tous les
fait comment dire politique qu'on a
connu depuis la dissolution mais disons
que entre 2019 et la dissolution de de
de juin 2024 dissolution raté pour le
président de la républi Alexis CER
concentrit un pouvoir assez considérable
et même aujourd'hui alors qu'il y a
François baayerou à matigon comme
François Baou ne dispose pas d'une
majorité
euh on le sait euh Alexis Caire qu'on
dit sur le départ il y a eu des article
de presse mais ça fait longtemps qu'on
le dit sur le départ donc là l'opinion
le journalopinion le le présente sur le
départ sur pour rejoindre la banque
Société Générale donc un un poste dans
le privé après après ses fonctions
depuis maintenant 7 ans à l'Élysée euh
et c'est vrai qu' en tout cas en tant
que journaliste moi je me suis toujours
posé et d'autres collègues bien
évidemment la question de de on va dire
du du du questionnement sur les
activités d'un de quelqu'un avec autant
de pouvoir à l'Élysée sans qu'on puisse
justement davantage
savoir qu quelle a pu être son rôle dans
différents dossiers notamment dossiers
industriel donc ça c'est chroniqué par
des enquêtes he moi-même j'ai travaillé
sur des dossiers où elle Alexis CER
était en première ligne euh mais disons
que c'est c'est pas fait dans la la
transparence parce que en tout cas c'est
pas Alexis CER contrairement au premier
ministre ne rend pas de compte devant le
Parlement et donc ça c'est une
spécificité de la 5e République en
France voilà qui est accentué par une
pratique du pouvoir ISEN aujourd'hui par
enfin par Emmanuel Macron comme je l'ai
dit extrêmement verticale extrêmement
concentré sur l'Élysée ces dossiers
d'armateur de construction de PbO ça
représente quel volume ça s'est vendu
combien c'est ça a été vendu c'est ça à
rodolp
sad quoi quoi c'est le même rodolp qui
est en train de créer 20000 emplo aux
États-Unis je me trompe ENF je vais
revenir sur les armateurs mais juste
avant parce que j'ai j'ai oublié j'avais
fait un teasing entre guillemets
technique quand je parlais de quand je
parlais de
Marianne j'ai parlé de la clause de
session clause de conscience donc pour
expliquer ce que c'est alors c'est un
c'est un droit spécifique au journaliste
euh la clause de conscience et la clause
de session euh protecteur parce que ça
permet à un journaliste de démissionner
euh tout en bénéficiant d'une danité en
fonction de son ancienneté et surtout
l'ouverture en droit du CH au chômage
euh même si c'est des droits au chômage
inférieurs un licenciement habituel ou
une rupture conventionnelle
euh c'est non négligeable en terme de
pourcentage hein d'ailleurs mais mais
combien vous gagnez chez Marianne euh
Marianne je gagnais euh 3008 net net net
euh avant impôt voilà
euh voilà c'est un poste à 5000 € brut
voilà c'est c'est un bon salaire de
grand reporter c'était le titre que
j'avais
euh voilà ça c'était mon salaire euh
mais euh donc la clause de conscience
euh c'est quand il y a un changement
majeur de ligne éditoriale
euh ce qui permet au journalistes
d'invoquer la conscience
pour sortir du projet euh et c'est mais
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
automatique normalement parce que le
journaliste doit justifier de la clause
de conscience et des raisons de la
clause de conscience ce que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure d' certain ère euh là
c'était un peu particulier dans le cadre
que je vous ai décrit euh parce que en
réalité c'est carrément le la la
direction qui a amené les journalistes à
enfin qui a justifié et qui a permis au
journaliste de justifier de la clause de
conscience d'une certaine manière c'est
faire hein c'est
fairplay bah c'est les c'est les c'est
les mot de Oliven quasiment sont c'est
vrai euh
voilà
euh et la clause de cession euh c'est
dans le cadre d'une session
d'actionnaire d'un changement
d'actionnaire majeur et donc le droit de
la presse je reviendrai peut-être la
Corée du Nord qui prend les
participations dans un canard oui enfin
mais globalement un changement
actionnarial d'un journal euh majeur
aussi permet aux journalistes là pour le
coup sans justification euh
de pouvoir partir et démissionner dans
le cadre du dispositif que j'ai
décrit globalement il y a peu de
journalistes qui le font enfin là c'est
un contreexemple concernant
Marianne en ce qui concerne la clause de
conscience reste que c'est un dispositif
protecteur mais qui à l'origine des lois
sur la presse et du
journalisme fa remonter pour ça aux
années 30 notamment o juste il y avait
des grands débats à l'époque
entre ce qu'on appelait les forces de
l'argent et la presse parce que il y a
eu il faut rappeler ça il y a eu des
grands scandales politico-financiers au
début du 20e siècle fin du 19e début du
20e siècle dans une actualité j'allais
dire très lourde parce que c'était avant
la Première Guerre mondiale pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale et entre les
deux
guerres ce qu'on a appelé communément le
bourrage de crâne aussi he avec des
situations de
propagande propagande étatique bien
évidemment mais surtout en ce qui
concerne les scandales
politico-financiers je pense au canal de
manab ou le scandale de Panama ou le
scandale de ce qu'on appelait les
emprunts russes aussi ou des choses
comme ça la presse a régulièrement à
l'époque été impliquée dans ces
scandales là parce que la profession des
journalistes était pas
organisé à l'époque on avait ce qu'on
appelait une presse
d'opinion très riche en France mais qui
finalement était encore peu
professionnalisé ce qui fait
que les journalistes avaient des
occupations principales des activités
principales et presque en titre de
loisir pouvait écrire dans ses
publication
d'opinion un peu comme aujourd'hui quand
des gens écrivent alors ils écrivent
plus des blogs maintenant mais enfin
même écrivent des choses sur Twitter ou
des choses comme ça si je fais la
comparaison un peu hasardeuse mais et
donc à l'époque
euh il y a des il y a des gens qui
avaient des intérêts financiers dans
certains dossiers
euh intérêts qu'on ne connaissait pas et
qui pouvait écrire dans la presse et
donc dans les années 20 dans les années
30 il y a eu un grand débat
professionnel
euh qui a donné la création de ce qu'on
appelle la Commission nationale de la
carte de presse pour savoir quel
critère constituait le groupe
professionnel c'està-dire quelle était
la frontière du groupe professionnel des
journalistes et donc en fait la décision
a été prise à
l'époque qu'il s'agissait de préserver
des critères
de de comment dire de traçabilité
économique c'est-à-dire est journaliste
professionnel journaliste qui euh peut
justifier de plus de 50 % de son
activité avec une entreprise de presse
comme salarié permanent ou régulier
pigiste ou irrégulier mais pigist donc
pigist c'est payé à la tâche à l'article
ou au reportage mais payer en salaire et
donc c'est ce système là qui a été
instauré ça a du bon parce que ça a
permis d'éjecter euh entre guillemets
les conflits d'intérêts que je vous ai
décrit juste avant et en même temps
euh et bien ça ça a mis c'est c'est une
conception assez libérale du du de la
profession parce que alors ça a du bon
et des aspects qui peuvent être parfois
plus criticquable
mais il n'y a pas d'ordre de la
profession pour comparer à d'autres
professionsoc min avocat et compagnie
parce que justement il y avait la
nécessité de préserver la liberté d'
accès à la profession
euh et qu'il n'y ait pas de de de
jugement d'ordre moral
ou justement déontologique
euh sur la qualité du travail d'un
journaliste ou pas donc ça c'est bon
côté aussi parce que ça permet de euh de
tout tout le monde qui travaille pour
une entreprise de presse dans le
pluralisme de la presse donc quel que
soit les positionnements politiques des
journaux quels que soi les lignes
éditoriales des journaux euh si personne
est payée par une entreprise de presse
elle peut avoir cette carte de
presse qui donne pas grand-chose en fait
parce que en
réalité 500 € non même même pas parce
qu'en fait l'abattement fiscal est lié à
au salaire spécifique au salaire avec
les cotisations sociales spécifiques de
la presse et mais c'est pas parce que on
n pas de com dire une carte de presse ça
va ça va faciliter les démarches
administratives auprès d'employeur et ça
va surtout facilit ça va donner une
protection juridique que ça soit par
rapport aux tribunaux par rapport aux
force de police par rapport aux
institutions donc c'est une préservation
de l'indépendance des journalistes
vis-à-vis des autres institutions de la
République secré des sources tout à fait
et c'est donc important et il faut
savoir que donc il y
a excusez-moi il y a eu il y a quelques
enfin il y a l'année dernière il y a eu
d'ailleurs une tribune de de de
journalistes qui n'ont pas accès à la
carte de presse car euh euh qui n'ont
pas accès à la carte de presse
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils n'ont pas
suffisamment d'activités avec dans des
entreprises de presse traditionnelles ou
sur internet en l'occurrence c'est des
journalistes euh qui comme moi ont une
activité éditoriale à travers des à
travers la publication de livres et le
versement de droits d'auteur et ces
versements de droits d'auteur ne sont
pas considérés comme une activité
journalistique ce qui est normal d'une
certaine manière parce que au regarde
des règles syndicales enfin des droits
sociaux c'est pas les cotisations qui à
travers des des droits d'auteur qui
permettent de la la conforation LAF la
conation la confirmation de du cadre
social des journalistes mais résultat
ces journalistes qui ont un travail au
long
cours ne sont pas protégés et n'ont pas
accès à la carte de presse donc il y a
tout un nouveau débat qui est lié alors
à travers certain un cas individuel de
journalistes qui peuvent avoir la chance
euh de de comment dire de faire des
livres donc je pense notamment à Victor
Castanet qui a travaillé sur les épades
qui a été un succès de librairie qui
fait que il a eu un gros droit d'auteur
à la fin ce qui lui permet de pouvoir
travailler et faire des enquêtes sur 2 3
ans voir 4 ans maintenant euh mais ne
lui donne pas accès à la carte de presse
euh mais au-delà de ces cas individuels
euh
c'est toute la question de la
précarisation de la la profession qui
fait que maintenant la Commission de la
carte a énormément
baissé l'accès à la à la à la carte euh
parce que en début de carrière euh la la
carte peut être cédée entre guillemets
par la Commission de la carte si on
justifie de 500 600 700
800 € par mois à peine euh ce qui montre
le niveau de rémunération de certains
journalistes aujourd'hui donc
extrêmement
précaire voilà et donc il y a des
accommodements par rapport au cadre
sacerdotal non hein c'est un sacerdosce
ah c'est un sacerdos ah oui bah ces
gens-là enfin bon une bonne partie des
journalistes comment dire se font
comment dire acceptent de se faire
exploiter si je prend cette
terminologie souvent par
passion par mission par du devoir pour
d'autres il y a il y a il n'y a pas que
les stars du du métier il y a il y a
aussi l'immense majorité des
journalistes et ces journalistes dont on
parle jamais euh et bien aujourd'hui il
faut le savoir il y a eu des études qui
on montré
que même des journalistes issus
d'écolees de journalisme ce qui n'est
pas ce donc pas obligatoire en regarde
de ce que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure sur
comment avoir la carte de presse euh on
peut être journaliste et avoir sa carte
de presse sans avoir fait descoes
journaliste c'est mon cas euh et bien
euh euh là j'ai un trou de mémoire
euh carte de presse salaire
précarisation ça sert
d'os j'ai un trou de mémoire on va
revenir sur trou de mémoire plus tard
les dossiers par exemple sur les
armateurs les les bateaux non enfin j'ai
pas retrouvé mais parce que on va partir
sur autre chose euh je décide oui
mais mais mais vous avez compris que
j'allais partir sur autre chose voilà et
euh non sur j'ai apporté des livres
c'est pas les miens mais pour pour bon
pour les gens qui sont motivés hein
parce que c'est un livre universitaire
mais c'est le c'est le meilleur
spécialiste de l'histoire du journalisme
en France c'est Christian Delport qui
est historien et qui donc au seuil c'est
un bouquin qui date de il y a 15 ans
mais sur une période historique de 1880
à 1950 c'est les journalistes en France
tout simplement et construction d'une
profession et là tous les débats euh de
l'entre de guerre sur la constitution du
groupe professionnels sont décrits par
le menu avec bah tout le travail
d'archiv et d'historien de Christian
Delport et voilà et ça je le recommande
en tout cas y compris pour les étudiants
au journalisme par exemple euh ils
apprendront plein de choses dans dans
dans dans ce livre mais il faut il faut
revenir à l'histoire parce que beaucoup
de choses sont dites et euh parfois les
gens le grand public ne comprend pas
forcément pourquoi la caste presse que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et donc voilà
là je suis revenu sur les Ch je revenir
à l'histoire parce que sinon on est
condamné à la revivre VO voilà revenons
à nos dossiers le volume de milliards de
centaines de millions c'est quoi le le
les les histoire avec Alexis CER c'est
des dossiers qui représentent combien de
millions combien de milliards combien de
pays combien de de réseau combien de
réseaux ah bah
MSC alors MSC n'est pas un groupe côté
en bourse donc c'est le mystère
euh beaucoup de gens ont dit opacité euh
par rapport au compte de la société on
secr des affaires on a
voilà et donc c'est un groupe familial
dont on connaît pas tous les
actionnaires mais principalement
contrôlé par la famille
euh qui pèse plusieurs milliards d'euros
euh ils ont gagné comme tous les armates
un peu enfin pendant le covid après un
peu avant je crois et 2 ans au moins
après le covid il y a eu contraction du
marché avec tous les bouleversements
qu'on a connu avec les les confinements
et et compagniees qui fait que enfin
contraction du marché que je veux dire
il y a eu une augmentation très forte du
prix du transport des containers
euh qui est le on va dire la la le
fluide de la globalisation et donc ces
groupes armateurs père voilà la MO
Pinière ces groupes d'armateurs ont
gagné tout d'un coup énormément d'argent
on parlait tout à l'heure de Saad donc
du groupe CMA CGM que j'ai déjà évoqué
j'ai plus exactement les chiffres en
tête mais en en une année CMA CGM je
crois qu' est le 5e armateur
mondial a gagné entre 25 milliards et 30
milliards d'euros en une année là je
parle de
bénéfice et donc c'est ça a été il y a
eu une rentrée d'argent assz
considérable alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que c'est des marché extrêmement
cyclique et qui peuvent passer d'un
extrême à l'autre et donc il faut savoir
que CMA CGM ou
MSC sont sortis de d'une histoire encore
récente il y a une dizaine d'années de
très graves difficultés d'où aussi leur
rapport respectif à aux différents états
et en tout cas à l'état français parce
que c macgm c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
réussi à obtenir une niche fiscale
extraordinaire ce qui fait que ils ont
quasiment une défisalisation quasiment
totale alors j'ai plus le détails hein
il a y a mais en tout cas ils payent
beaucoup moins d'impôts sur leurs
activités et ça c'est parce que les les
les différents gouvernements français
ont considéré que il était stratégique
de de préserver un armateur
euh lié en partie à la France he cmacgm
est situé à Marseille le le siège social
euh tout à l'heure on évoquait euh
euh Rodolf sad donc qui a investi
également lui dans les
médias euh et qui est également proche
euh de l'Élysée
euh plutôt au départ de ce qu'on
appelait l'elle Madame Brigitte Macron
d'ailleurs parce que justement Alexis
CER avec MSC faisait que bon peut-être
que la la meilleure entrée auprès du
couple Macron bah c'était le couple
directement donc la famille Saadé qui
historiquement était proche de Jacques
Chirac je le rappelle euh s'est
rapproché de du de l'Élysée assez
rapidement
euh ça se rapproche comment c'est ça
sonne à la porte ça
appelle ça passe par plein de des
copains par des non non mais c'est même
des choses très directes hein il suffit
de regarder l'organigramme de cmacgm
hein il y a des haut-fonctionnaires qui
ont été recrutés euh il y a des anciens
conseillers notamment un je pense un
ancien conseiller qui est passé par
Élisée justement qui travaillait avec en
particulier Brigitte Macron enfin en
partie j'ai aucune chance de décrocher
une une interview de Brigitte Macron en
lui envoyant une boîte de chocolat bah
ça je sais pas faut demander à Rodolf
Saad je ne sais pas et donc Rodolph Saad
je le rappelle bon maintenant ça se sait
mais a investi plusieurs enfin une somme
assez conséquente un milliard je crois
je sais plus non j'ai plus les chiffres
mais enfin une somme très conséquente
combien de zé au milliard non c'est pas
un milliard y a combien de zé à 1
milliard euh il y a combien de Zard il
en a en a a 6 je crois non ah non c'est
un million et on a 9 merci voilà
euh
euh on arrêtera de faire la blague la
saison prochaine non non non parce que
je
réfléchissais pour déconcentrer ouais
c'est ça c'est ça j'aimerais qu'on parle
un peu de Thierry Breton on va pas ouais
mais je veux juste finir sur sm acgm
donc c'est comme ça qu'ils ont acheté
BFM TV enfin c'est comme ça c'est c'est
çaad a un investissement dans les médias
lui aussi c'est quoi vos sources c'est
c'est publ bah là c'est public oui enfin
là c'est public non ce qui est très
intéressant depuis quelques temps c'est
de voir le mécano des armateurs
c'est-à-dire
euh désolé hein je reviens sur les trucs
qu'on a dit mais c'est
euh là peut-être que les gens l'ont pas
vu mais donc rodalf sad s'est retrouvé
dans le bureau oval de Donald Trump
devant les caméras pour annoncer 20
milliards de de dollars d'investissement
aux États-Unis il faut savoir que acgm
euh à la fois des routes maritimes vers
l'Asie euh donc onticulier la Chine euh
mais à multiplier les activités les
acquisitions aux États-Unis ces
dernières années à tel point qu'ils ont
rachetter
euh une compagnie qui est un des
principaux sous-traitants de l'armée
américaine pour le transport des troupes
américaines euh au niveau maritime euh
enfin en tout cas tout ce qui est euh
euh transport des troupes en tout cas
tout ce qui est également lié comment
dire à la chaîne d'approvisionnement de
l'armée américaine un marché porteur
donc et stratégique donc c'est aussi
pour ça que les armateurs ont des liens
avec les gouvernements parce que à la
fois ils ont des activités où circulent
bah beaucoup d'éléments stratégiques ils
peuvent avoir des liens donc là
quasiment de défense avec les
gouvernements et puis il contrôle par
des filiales souvent des ports en direct
euh et donc euh av pas un Français qui
avait des ports ou du moins des
activités dans des ports oui oui alors
on va arriver on va arriver parce que
c'est c'est un épisode qui a été
relativement peu relaté euh parce que
c'est moins sexy peut-être que Bernard
Arnaud xaviniel je ne sais pas mais
enfin en tout cas euh ça ça beaucoup de
gens le savent mais pas tant que ça mais
je vais je vais je vais revenir sur un
certains un certain épisode mais donc
CMA CGM Rodolf sad
euh a accouru dans le bureau oval de
Donald Trump pour créer de l'emploi
ouais on on va dire ça mais en tout cas
pas de l'emploi en Europe mais par
contrecoup on va dire et dans le même
temps on a appris que Donald Trump
reprenait entre guillemets le contrôle
américain du canal de Panama et donc
avec Black Rock oui Black Rock c'est le
volet c'est le volet financier parce que
parce que le on a appris que le volet
opérationnel de l'opération sur le
Panama donc qui dégageait la compagnie
Hong Kongaise donc chinoise qui gérait
jusqu'à présent le canal de Panama en
tout cas ces dernières années on a
appris que l'opérationnel qui allait
charger notamment des ports aux entrées
du du canal c'était til qui est la
filiale
MSC voilà parce que dans til qui est la
filiale une des filiales de gestion de
port d'
MSC il y a dans capital euh Black Rock
voilà donc il y a des liens là
actionnario fort importants euh très
très intéressant à étudier et à et à
comprendre et ça concerne également le
mécano financier français euh parce que
effffectivement en 2021
euh
Boloré le groupe Boloré euh et bien à a
décidé ça faisait déjà en fait quelques
temps qu'ils avaient envisagé mais de
céder ce qu'on appelle les activités
africaines logistiques et portuaires du
groupe Boloré en Afrique de l'Ouest et
même logistique en en Afrique de l'Est
euh ils ont donc vendu leur filiale
africaine Boré logistique Afrique
finalement à MSC pour 5,7 milliards
d'euros et ça c'est des négociations
exclusives qui sont étalés entre
novembre 2021 et avril 2022 euh
l'annonce euh de la conclusion totale du
deal s'est faite je crois quelques jours
après l'élection présidentielle en
France
euh et ça c'est ça je le racontais dans
mon avantdernier livre l'emprise parce
qu'il y avait tout un chapitre enfin il
y avait déjà des chapitres sur colère
mais il y avait tout un chapitre sur
Boloré et je pointais que l'origine
d'ailleurs à l'époque de la guerre entre
Boloré et l'Élysée provenait des
difficultés en tout cas le sentiment de
Boloré de ne pas avoir suffisamment été
soutenu par lesél à partir de 2017 euh
alors même qu'il avait aidé enfin son
son groupe de médias et d'influence
avait aidé le candidat Macron avant 2017
on a tendance à l'oublier c'est de la
spéculation c'est un point ah non c'est
des faits bah les les les les principaux
conseillers en communication d'Emmanuel
Macron de l'époque notamment Ismaël
mélien a fait toute sa carrière au sein
du groupe avas qui est une des
principale agence d'influence et de
communication de sur la place de Paris
dont l'actionnaire est Vincent boloret
faire l'avocat du diable peut-être qu'on
a payé une société pour conseiller
Emmanuel
Macron c'est-à-dire c'est un service ah
bah B alors justement il y a eu tout il
y a tout le dossier dont plus personne
ne parle même moi je ne sais pas où son
ce dossier est parti la fameuse affaire
business France euh
ù à l'époque donc a été mise en cause
les liens entre business France qui est
une agence de l'État enfin liée à Bercy
et et l'organisation d'un événemen CEL à
Las Vegas notamment en janvier
2016 non ça je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas événement où était présent le
ministre de l'Économie Emmanuel Macron
et cet événement était organisé par
l'agence avas comme une
partie de de de l'activité de business
France qui est chargé de
promouvoir les exportations françaises
et l'attractivité plus expplortation
français d'ailleurs à
l'étranger une partie des des contrats
était entre entre Bercy et avas à
l'époque et donc effectivement des
questions se sont posées sur
euh une éventuelle aide ce qu'on appelle
probono gratuite auprès du candidat
Macron ensuite en 2016 2017 pass pas
dans les compes de
compagne pass ça passe pas dans les
comptes de campagne non bah si c'est du
proono ça c'est gratuit donc ça passe
pas effectivement dans les comptes de
campagne mais c'est la même
problématique donc manifestement la
justice a pas continuer son œuvre je
parce que après une mise en cause ils
ont rien trouvé ils ont peut-être rien
trouvé en tout
cas effectivement moi-même je me suis
plus penché sur ce dossier là de
business France qui avait éclaté en 2017
on s'en souvient dans la presse ce qui a
été présenté comme l'affaire penico mais
bon l'affaire penico ministre qui avait
été nommé ministre penico étant en poste
à business France mais en réalité le
lien qui était intéressant c'était
Ismaël mélien qui était le principal
conseiller stratégique du ministre
Macron à l'époque avec avec l'agence
avas et et et donc à l'époque
euh donc la question ensuite s'est posée
avec mckinse d'ailleurs pour les pour
les les les services probono pendant la
campagne don là il y a là il y a un
dossier judiciaire qui est en cours euh
la présomption d'innocence parce que je
rappelle euh par ailleurs que donc euh
en France les entreprises peuvent pas
faire de don à des candidats mais les
entreprises ou toute personne ou
institution ne peut pas faire de de de
de cadeau au candidats parce que c'est
considéré comme du financement illégal
de campagne électorale euh et donc euh à
l'époque en 2016-27 euh avas mais
également certains médias bolorés donc
canal plus avait largement relayé des
campagnes de communication autour du
ministre de l'économie hein on se
souvient par exemple de Cyril Eldin qui
promenait son micro et qui suivait le
ministre il y avait des beaucoup de
vignettes comme ça au petit journal je
crois euh on suivait Cyril d'eldin et
cyrileldin faisait partie des des des
des privilégiés avoir accès au ministre
de l'économie à l'époque Emmanuel Macron
on se souvient également mais enfin je
dis on se souvient mais on a tendance à
oublier que entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle euh je crois me souvenir
c'était entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron avait été
invité en duplexe avec Cyril Hanouna
dans son émission donc quand je dis
qu'il y avait des liens forts avant
l'élection 2017 ils sont établis quoi
ils sont totalement établis et donc pour
la pour l'histoire c'est qu'après 2017
Vincent Boloré a considéré qu'en réalité
l'Élysée ne le soutenait pas
suffisamment sur ses activités
africaines euh et que l'État français ne
le soutenait pas suffisamment dans ses
activités en Afrique notamment dans les
relations auprès des des chefs d'État et
donc ça a développé on va dire une
animosité de Vincent Boloré vis-à-vis de
l'Élysée dont et en fait colère Alexis
Caire était soupçonné de partialité avec
l'armateur MSc en fait dans ces liens de
proximité là je je reprends le point de
vue de Vincent Boloré en tout cas tel
que j'ai pu le reconstituer à l'enquête
c'est des suputations non c'est des
témoignages c'est des témoignages
recueillis de de d'anciens du groupe
Boloré de gens dans l'écosystème à la
galaxie Boloré et d'ailleurs donc
quand finalement les activités de Boloré
Afrique ont été vendu à MSc en fait très
vite il y a eu enfin pendant l'élection
présidentielle et même après il y a eu
en fait une détente des relations entre
Emmanuel Macron et Boloré on est on en
est plus du tout là aujourd'hui parce
que on est revenu on va dire à à la case
départ j'allais dire enfin la case
départ du du premier quinena oou de
nouveau là les les les frictions sont
importantes notamment idéologiques euh
mais sur toute cette période-là
euh ce qui est intéressant à voir c'est
que bien évidemment ce dossier-là était
central euh je veux dire le dossier des
activités africaines de de Boloré et
elles ont été peu chroniqué dans les
médias ce qui fait que les médias ont
été un peu à cont-temps dans la
chronique euh de la réalité des rapports
entre Vincent Boloré et Emmanuel Macron
ils avaient un temps de retard ils
avaient de mon point de vue ils avaient
un temps de retard c'est-à-dire que mais
après on va revenir à C macgm parce que
c'est aussi important mais euh de mon
point de vue ils avaient un temps de
retard parce qu'en fait
euh le la guerre Boloré Macron entre
guillemets elle a été dépeinte au départ
par des journalistes médias sur le
dossier lagarder sur le fait que donc
Arnaud lagarder retrouvver en très forte
difficulté financière et sa banque
notamment le Crédit Agricole demandait
le remboursement d'énormément d'argent
et donc il était entre Bernard Arnaud et
Vincent boloret sur la sur le contrôle
du groupe et puis en
fait c'est à cette occasion là qu'on a
vu des frictions avec l'Élysée mais ce
n'est uniquement les rubriquard médiia
qui en parlait dans les médias les
journalistes chargés de suivre les
médias les journalistes politiques
comment pensé à s'autoriser à parler de
la défiance réciproque entre l'Élisée et
Boloré uniquement à la fin de 2020
pourquoi s'autoriser c'était de
l'autocensure cé non c'est la c'est
enfin c'est l'autocensure le terme est
fort disons que les journalistes
politiques ils restent dans leur canal
c'est-à-dire les petites phrases les
petites confidences du personnel
politique et ils font notamment en
France il il travaille pas sur les
politiques publiques c'està-dire il
travaille pas justement sur les
milliards dont on parlait tout à l'heure
sur concernant MSC il travaille pas sur
les dossiers industriels ou ou ou
politique y compris quand c'est des
dossiers industriels où justement les
responsables politiques doivent donner
des décisions et donc ils analysent pas
les intérêts économiques et financiers
qu' peut y avoir autour de l'État dans
leur pratique du journalisme politique
euh c'est c'est c'est du journalisme
people politique c'est ça oui bah c'est
l'évolution du journalisme politique
aussi de ces dernières années
personnalisation on fait des portraits
euh on il faut avoir accès à la au
responsables politique ça aussi c'est
contrainte là je renvoie euh j'ai pas
apporté le livre j'aurais pu l'apporter
je renvoie à mon confrère de libération
Rachid Larche qui a fait un livre sur
son expérience de journaliste politique
et lui pour le coup euh euh on parlait
de sacerdoce tout à l'heure enfin il
évoque son parcours de converti et puis
de où il est sorti de la case de
journaliste politique parce qu'il fait
un un portrait au vitriol des habitudes
des journalistes politiques il compris
les siennes quand il était en poste
politique enfin au service politique de
lib il est toujours journaliste
libération mais donc dans son livre don
j'ai oublié le nom
euh pénitence oui oui dans son oui oui
dans son
livre enfin c'est pas qu'il s'excuse
mais qui dit j'ai aussi pourquoi en gros
il explique pourquoi il a participé
aussi aux petites habitudes des
journalistes politique et il s'en est il
s'en est éloigné parce que il ne
trouvait plus sens dans ce travail là et
donc il a décidé d'être nommé ailleurs
euh dans dans à Libé donc
euh donc pour revenir au au cont-temps
journalistique sur ces dossiers
industriels et d'influence parce que ça
c'est quand même assez important parce
que sur ces dossiers
industriels euh ça ça ça a des
conséquences notamment parce que une
parti euh là on a cité plein de noms
c'est des propriétaires de médias donc
c'est des gens qui même s'ils ont pas
forcément un bouton pour dicter la ligne
éditoriale parfois c'est c'est plus
trivial mais parfois non parfois c'est
plus trivial donc parfois c'est c'est
c'est je procède par ehémisme mais oui
non parfois c'est parfois c'est subtile
parfois ça l'est pas voilà mais parfois
il y a il y a même pas besoin on parlait
d'autocensure parfois il y a même pas
besoin d'appeler d'appuyer sur le bouton
il suffit d'embaucher la bonne
hiérarchie dans dans les rédactions
voilà l' au censure vient souvent des
hiérarchies des rédaction plus que des
journalistes même mais mais quand même
ils
ont un poids une influence on parlait
des oligarques dans dans dans le cadrage
médiatique et donc démocratique de la
vie publique en France 90 % des médias
sont la propriété de cadrage ou cord
d'acage cadrage parce
que comment dire justement là je vais
dire c'est plus subtile même si si il y
a beaucoup de dénonciation y compris des
journalistes mêmees aujourd'hui qui
s'aperçoivent que ils se sont fait
largement avoir même si tout ça était
prévisible mais ils se sont laissés
déposséder de leur pouvoir
journalistique et il y a plus
d'autonomie des rédaction du tout ou en
tout cas très peu en dehors de quelques
institutions c'est votre point de vue je
suis obligé de le dire oui mais bon ça
ça c'est c'est mon point de vue qui
signifie pourquoi j'ai pris ma clause de
conscience hein aussi voilà donc
euh
euh voilà euh et donc euh donc bien
évidemment que ça une influence cette
propriété des médias je parlais des
forces de l'argent dans les années 30 ou
même après la guerre quand les
résistants ont relancé la presse déjà
sous l'Occupation puis après la guerre
bien évidemment cette question là des
des moyens de production de la presse
était posé alors encore plus aujourd'hui
dans un monde euh en totale
dstructuration au monde de la presse et
des médias avec les réseaux sociaux avec
le numérique qui a fait exploser tous
les cadres de l'économie de la presse
euh pour que ça soit plus concret tout à
l'heure je parlais de diffusion divisée
par 2 en en 5 ans euh on est passé là
pour les news mag en gros de de pour
ceux qui vendent le plus entre on est
passé de 50000 payer 50000 exemplaires
payer kiosque à 25000 voilà
euh revenons à à la guerre du château ou
la guerre avec les les propriétaires de
médias les oligarques les châteaux et
donc je disais à cont-etemps
effectivement je reviens et donc je
disais à contre souvent la chronique
journalistique est à conttemps parce que
les les changements d'alliance les
changements d'intérêt bah sont on
parlait du secret des affaires sont
souvent dans le secret au départ et donc
euh
il y a toujours un temps de latence
entre la prise de conscience du du du du
petit discours médiatique même de la
rumeur parisienne du monde des affaires
bon actuellement je suis en train de
travailler sur un livre qui concerne la
vie du monde et la vie le monde des
affaires à Paris sur la place de Paris
comme on dit communément place
économique et financière de Paris je
suis quand même très frappé de voir
qu'en réalité en France euh les acteurs
économique même les puissants même les
propriétaires de médias même les les
entrepreneurs sont parfois très mal
informé et son toxique sutoinxique
parfois eux-mêmes euh de de de du fait
qu'ils sont qu'ils sont en fait très mal
informé et donc euh donc d'où le fait
que dans ces univers de pouvoirs
parisiens politique et économique c'est
parfois les principaux vecteurs de plein
de rumeurs sur le monde des affaires ou
le monde politique euh qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité des
choses et donc là en l'occurrence sur le
conttemps euh c'est simple euh donc en
décembre 2020 on était là euh les c'est
à partir seulement de décembre 2020 que
les journalistes politiques se sont
autorisés à parler de la guerre bolorer
Élysée parce qu'en fait fin décembre
2020 il y a une dépêche Reuters donc une
grande
agence anglaise d'information du même
type que la FP qui fait une dépêche
intitulée l'Élysée euh a peur d'une Fox
News à la française en parlant de ces
news et la dépêche est assez longue
c'est ce qu'on appelle une dépêche je
crois enfin thématique quoi et et donc
qui est pas lié à une actualité
précise mais la dépêche tient à partir
de citation off c'est non sourcé
totalement en tout cas pas
nominativement mais sourcé un conseiller
de l'Élysée nous explique la situation
et en fait ce n'est uniquement qu'à
partir de cette dépêche là que les
journalistes dans leur ensemble les
journalistes politique en particulier se
sont autorisés au moins à comprendre on
va dire que il y avait des tensions
entre le groupe Boloré et l'Élysée parce
que les rebrecard médiia regardaient ça
vraiment sous l'angle quand même
économique et médiatique concernant le
dossier la gardèire moi je me souviens
que ma chronique à la tribune qui était
un peu transversale
justement et ça c'est la difficulté des
médias traditionnels c'est de pas de mon
point de vue d'être pas suffisamment
transversal et d'être dans leur rubrique
dans leur couloir de nage c'est à peu
près le problème des agences de
renseignementoui tout à fait de plein
d'institutions effectivement et donc moi
je pense par qu'on est dans un monde en
totale révolution et
dstructuration mutation et donc dans ce
monde en mutation il faut regarder si on
regarde pas les choses d'un manière
transversale si on décloisonne pas on
peut pas comprendre tout parce que on ne
fait que répéter des des schémas de
pensé des cadrages pour reprendre le
terme du passé et donc on on fait pas
évoluer la compréhension ni auprès du
public ni pour nous-même en tout cas
journaliste de des dossiers là en
l'occurrence euh euh et bien sur ce
dossier-là ce n'est que à partir de 2021
que les journalistes politiques s'en
sont donné à cœurjoie dans plein de
papier pour expliquer que le le grand
danger était Boloré pour Emmanuel Macron
alors on se souvient qu'à l'époque
effectivement Boloré ne se cachait pas
de senir la candidature d'Éric Zemour
euh bien évidemment euh et ce n'est pas
anodin euh sauf qu'on a vu également que
et même Éric Zemour je crois que s'en
est plein au moins auprès de son
entourage en tout cas il y a eu de la
chronique par la suite euh par rapport à
sa contreperformance électorale ensuite
à l'élection de 2017 euh 2022
excusez-moi euh il il comment dire il a
bien vu qu'il avait pas été finalement
aussi soutenu qu'il pensait par Boloré
et puis surtout
euhouv une parenthèse petite précision
c'est le syndrome baladure c'est de 95
les responsables politiques euh font des
cours pour bête au puissant et au aux
responsables de médias mais on est
encore en démocratie et donc au final
c'est quand même les Français qui se
décident et qui vote et donc baladure
croyait remporter la manche en 95 en
récupérant une bonne partie des relais
d'influence médiatique et industriel du
pays à l'époque et finalement c'est
Jacques Chirac qui a gagné donc toujours
mettre un bémol quand même à à à au
caractère mécanique des choses de ce
point de vue-là mais pour poursuivre
juste la l'analyse du entreotemp
euh voilà entre 2021 et 2022 en fait le
dossier MSC Boloré avec vente des
activités africaines à Boloré euh de
Boloré à MSC excusez-moi dans le même
temps CMA CGM qui était également un
acteur de la négociation en Afrique euh
et bien se désengage du dossier en
octobre 2021 c'estàdire ils ne
surenchérissent pas par rapport à
l'offre faite par MSC
mais ils font deux choses par la suite
ils entrent dans le capital de Air
France en janvier 2022 cmacgm et c'est
annoncé en janvier 2022 ils le sont plus
aujourd'hui ou plus totalement ils ont
je sais plus exactement où ils en sont
mais il ils sont ils ont en parti ils
sont un parti revenus ils étaient ils
étaient intéressés par les activités
logistiques de enfin de de fret de d'Air
France mais ça ça s'est fait en bonne
intelligence avec l'État et avec l'élysé
hein Air France compination nationale
stratégique et C macgm
infin je sais plus les dates précises
mais c'est après le deal MSC va racheter
l'ensemble des activités logistiques de
Boloré hors Afrique et notamment vers
l'Asie qui était comme je le rappelais
tout à l'heure une des un des axes
prioritaires de cmacgm et donc là il y a
eu une sorte de Yalta des armateurs
entre MSC cm CGM entre et
Boloré dire un jeu à 3 et bien
évidemment ce jeu à 3 euh l'Élysée a
regardé ça de près c'est un des c'est un
dossier sur lequel euh l'Élysée a
regardé ça de près à tel point que sur
un dossier plus microscopique pour ces
grandes puissances financières je veux
parler de du dossier de la Provence don
du du quotidien local la Provence à
Marseille il y avait une guerre
euh très forte entre xavieniel qui était
déjà actionnaire je crois en tout cas
déjà investisseur dans La Provence et
qui était proche de Bernard tapi et
Bernard tapi avait demandé à xavienel de
racheter la Provence à sa mort et à son
âme voilà et en face Saad qui donc en
partie à Marseille voulait mettre la
main sur sur la Provence et donc il y
avait une lutte entre ces deux
propriétaires de médias et et et
finalement c'est Saad qui a remporté la
manche mais on sait que c'est lors d'un
voyage officiel où Macron a réussi à à
mettre dans le même avion rodolp Saad et
xavierel qu'on va dire que la
réconciliation s'est faite totalement
sur le dossier de la Provence donc la
bien évidemment il y a des liens très
forts entre Emmanuel Macron et ses
grands propriétaires de médias et puis
surtout ses grandes puissances
financière je ne dis pas que il y a eu
des décisions de l'État sur C sur ces
deal financiers et privé mais on le
rachat d'un journal c'est politique
aussi quand même euh bien évidemment
et je donnerai une anecdote que j'ai
jamais
relaté tout à l'heure pour illustrer ça
mais pour revenir sur le contetemps je
suis désolé d'être un peu long mais
c'est important
euh donc pour moi entre 2021 et 2022
toutes les conditions se réuni d'un
rapprochement entre Boloré et l'Élysée
et c'est ce qui se passe en réalité
alors bien évidemment Macron gagne et à
partir de là les relations s'apèisent
mais les relations s'apèisent parce que
tous ces deals financiers ont se sont
constitués et euh et donc pour moi la
réconciliation elle date de cette
époque-là la la presse et notamment en
l'occurrence le monde a mis beaucoup de
temps à à s'apercevoir ou en tout cas à
écrire que la réquation réconciliation
avait eu lieu il y a eu un article euh
qui a été publié en décembre
2023 pour expliquer que la
réconciliation avait eu lieu à partir de
septembre 2023 euh or l'été rappelé
appz-vous bon l'été 2023 Boré prend
totalement le contrôle du Journal du
Dimanche à l'époque qui était encore en
contrôle par le groupe la garder et
indirectement Boloré mais à l'été 2023
c'est Boloré qui prend totalement le
contrôle du Journal du Dimanche et c'est
notamment josefro Lejeune qui était
l'ancien directeur de la rédaction de
valeur actuelle journal à droite très à
droite d'extrême droite pour certains et
bien d'extrême droite pour moi en tout
cas et donc Joff Lejeune arrive au
Journal du Dimanche et il y a toute une
polémique dans la macronie qui estar pas
il arrive pas pour rien ah ben non il
non je le jeune n'arrive pas pour rien
et et et josf Lejeune est un très proche
ami des histoires de caricature un peu
infamante quelque part là-dedans non bon
bah le valeur actuel a été condamné dans
le dossier au bonau notamment
euh très fortement pour des caricatures
racistes je crois et et donc en en en
joint 2023 donc juste avant le prise
total de contrôle Geoffre le jeune est
nommé à la tête du JDD ça provoque une
crise de la rédaction parce que on sait
que les journalistes là pour le coup
partent avant et après d'ailleurs il y a
eu plusieurs successives il y a des il y
a eu des vagu
successives c'est plutôt des comment
dire rupture conventionnelle à ma
connaissance qu'il y a eu à l'époque pas
clause de concession clause de
conscience et mais négocier
collectivement les conventionnelle Dans
me souvenir et euh et à l'époque
euh et donc à l'époque euh le JDD est
pris sous le contrôle de cette équipe
éditoriale et clairement depuis le JDD a
a réorienter sa ligne traditionnelle qui
était on va dire centriste on va dire
avant euh de centre- droit
euh et euh il y a eu une Inc
incompréhension dans les troupes
macronistes parce que plusieurs
ministres pas et beaucoup en fait on
commençait à donner des interviews au
JDD et donc ça a fait des ça créé des
polémiques parce qu'il y a des des
macronist on dit mais comment vous osez
euh donner des interviews au
jddé et la ligne de la ligne de défense
des ministres a été pour certains mais
nous avons le visa de l'Élysée nous
avons le visa de l'Élysée nous avons été
autorisés à donner des interview au JDD
et il faut rappeler par ailleurs que j
frois le jeune il arrive pas au hasard à
la tête du JDD euh c'est Bruno Roger
petit qui a joué un rôle conseiller à
l'Élysée très proche de Brigitte Macron
conseiller mémoire officiellement ancien
porte-parole de l'Élysée Brena Roger
petit qui est encore dans les murs dont
certains pensent qu'il finira par
éteindre les lumières à la fin des deux
quinenas Bruno Roger petit donc qui est
un ami de Geoffroy Lejeune et bien
évidemment Bruno je l'appelle par son
prénom parce que je le connais euh un de
ses sports favoris c'est de tout
répercuter auprès du chef de de l'état
de tous les cancans toutes les euh
toutes les les rumeurs toutes les tous
les bruits de la vie des rédactions euh
pour savoir qui est qui qui fait quoi
euh et donc également aime bien parfois
susciter certains trajectoire de de
carrière oui bien évidemment et ils sont
réconciliés ou pas ah bah à l'époque ils
étaient réconciliés et et pour moi ils
étaient réconcilié en fait dès la fin
2021 au moins et euh assurément en 2022
et sauf que la presse a dit seulement
donc c'est le monde qui l'a dit
seulement en 2023
réconciliation
réconciliation qui comment dire qui a
été qui aurait été faite selon le monde
moi j'ai pas ces informations là même si
ça a joué mais qui a été faite par un
personnage dont j'ai pas encore parlé
mais qui est important qui est Frédéric
Michel Frédéric Michel est un
communicant ou plutôt un lobbyiste parce
que c'est lui-même qui c'est lui-même
qui se présente comme tel qui n'est qui
qui qui a peu été découvert par le grand
public qui pourtant un personnage
important c'est un conseiller qui a
arrivé à la communication de l'Élysée en
dans mon souvenir en septembre 2022 je
l'avais annoncé dans la tribune j'avais
fait son portrait dans un article de La
Tribune euh le titre de mémoire c'était
l'arrivée d'un spin doctor à
l'américaine à l'Élysée spin doctor et
l'expression américaine pour dire
justement communiquant d'influence
communiquant de crise on spin on donne
la l'histoire on fait le storytelling
des dossiers politiques voilà et on on
manipule c'est la profession des
communicant de de communiquer et pas
d'informer la nuance est extrêmement
importante et donc Frédéric michelan
Médi part ça c'est pas un un slogan
méiaap part communiquer n'est pas
informé euh non informé n'est pas un
délier aussi mais oui mais mais et donc
Frédéric Michel c'est un personnage
important parce qu'il a travaillé
pendant plus de 20 ans pour le groupe
Murdock
euh et et donc le groupe Murdock pour
expliquer le groupe Murdock c'est le
l'un des plus gros groupe de presse
international le Mania repert Murdock
est australien il a quasiment toute la
presse australienne il a The Times
britannique il a le Sun le tableoï
londoni énormément de scandales derrière
et énormément de scandales derrière et
d'ailleurs Frédéric Michel a été au cœur
de de ces scandales là parce que il a
même été auditionné par une commission
d'enquête parlementaire au Royaume-Uni
euh alors scandale en deux mots pour que
les gens comprennent c'est il y a eu
donc il y a une dizaine d'années je
crois maintenant il y a eu un énorme
scandale à Londres avec d'ailleurs
c'était pas le Sun c'était News of the
World je crois euh où le donc qui était
un autre tableoïde de la sphère Murdock
et où en fait il y avait des liens
éditoriaux entre
euh donc entre la la rédaction en chef
de de de de de ces journaux people enfin
c énormes puissances he qui déstabilise
les responsables politiques il y avait
des liens avec des officines de
renseignement et des et surtout une
industrialisation d'écoute euh c'est
incroyable comme scandale d'écoute
quasiment généralisé de toute la classe
politique britannique et et événementiel
cétait avant Pegasus tout ça voilà
c'était avant Pegasus et et donc c'est
un énorme scandale qu'impliquait donc un
un tabloïde qui récoltait une partie des
informations issues de ses écoutes euh
enfin je crois que je me trompe pas he
je crois que c'était ça et donc le
groupe Murdock était le groupe Murdock
était en en première ligne parce qu'ils
étaient propriétaires de ces journaux là
d'ailleurs News of the World là aussi il
faut que je me souvienne mais euh
à a fini par fermer euh
et donc le groupe Murdock c'est
également Fox News justement
et aux États-Unis
c'est également donc Fox News c'est il
me semble qu'àun moment donné ça a été
la bah donc le studio américain Century
Fox mais je sais plus exactement et
c'est le New York Post on va dire
journal très
populaire aux États-Unis et une
institution de la presse économique et
financière le Wall Street Journal et
donc le groupe c'est une puissance
énorme qui a quasiment fait l'élection
de Tony Blair en en
Grande-Bretagne il y a quelques années
parce que Tony Blair qui était issu du
parti travailliste ou plutôt qu'a créé
le New labor donc on va dire un parti
travailliste passé à la sauce néolibéral
à fond la caisse donc il plus grand
chose de gauche Tony Blair était devenu
le petit préféré de Robert mordock et
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça que Frédéric
Michel a commencé sa carrière au groupe
dans le groupe Robert Mordoc parce qu'il
venait des équipes Blair euh et donc
c'est Frédéric Michel qui arrive à
l'Élysée il faut le rappeler dès
septembre 2022 c'est quand même très
important et et donc le monde explique
que c'est Frédéric Michel qui a organisé
la la la réconciliation
avec avec comment dire entre l'Élysée et
Boloré mais moi j'ai pas ces
informations là il a participé bien
évidemment à une meilleure entente euh
d'autant plus que féc Michel connaît
Boloré en direct connaî connaît l'agence
Savas propriétaire de Boloré et Stéphan
fou son propriétaire connaît Xavier Niel
en direct également mais connaissait
également Berlusconi il a travaillé en
Italie il connaî tous ces gens-là il les
tutoi tout à fait non mais c'est pour
donner le l'accès et la la la le poids
de Frédéric Michel dans le dispositif
euh et donc pourquoi je dis contetemps
parce que si je termine l'histoire en
fait en décembre 2023 le monde fait une
manchette en en sur cet article là
euh dans la même une du monde c'est le
jour je crois où la loi immigration
passe donc en gros ça permet au monde de
dire regardez comment Macron a
totalement viré à droite depuis très
longtemps enfin pas depuis très
longtemps ça c'est mon point de vue mais
vire à droite en fait Macron est
beaucoup plus à droite qu'on pense
depuis très longtemps ça c'est mon point
de vue et c'est mon point de vue lié à
mes enquêtes et à l'histoire d'Emmanuel
Macron
euh et euh et en fait donc en décembre
2023 le monde annonce la réconciliation
mais en fait au cours de l'année 2024 et
2025 en fait quelques mois à peine après
cette réconciliation
immédiatement c'est-à-dire euh assez
vite c'est-à-dire à partir même euh au
moment de la dissolution 6 mois après
l'article du Monde au moment de la
dissolution on voyait déjà que le groupe
Boloré faisait monter entre guillemets
était très sympathique en tout cas
vis-à-vis de Jordan bardellaa et de sa
campagne notamment aux européennes et
donc en réalité
euh c'est j'allais dire des vastes
communiquants ça bouge ça c'est vrai ça
il peut y avoir des
retournements de proximité très vite
très rapide et surtout du chantage de
ces groupes de médias et de
communication auprès des pouvoirs
politiques je parle chantage à dessin
c'est-à-dire là je vais revenir dans le
passé pour m'extraire de la de de
l'histoire récente mais dans le passé
euh tout le monde se souvient maintenant
de d'un fait unique dans une démocratie
c'estd la privatisation de la première
chaîne de télévision publique TF1 euh
privatisation qui a été réalisée en
période de cohabitation Shirak miterin
entre 86 et 88 euh sur piste il y a le
groupe lagardèire Jean-Luc lagardre qui
veut racheter TF1 mais il y a également
bug avec Robert Maxwell Mania
britannique des médias également à
l'époque qui veulent racheter euh TF1
finalement c'est bug et Maxwell qui
récupèent euh qui remporte TF1 il y a
accord en fait euh bipartisan j'allais
dire à l'époque entre Chirac la droite
et miteran et et et et sauf que euh
miteran gagne en 88 élection
présidentielle et là il y a un
retournement buig qui doit en partie
leur achat de tfin aussi à miteran c'est
raconté dans un livre euh d'enquête un
illustre prédécesseur Pierre Péant TF1
un pouvoir tout simplement ça s'appelle
TF1 un pouvoir qu'il a publié en 1997 et
et cette histoire là continue parce que
88 miteran gagne puis finalement big et
l'ensemble du groupe TF1 se retourne
contre miteran euh et puis mitteran se
rapproche à la fin de sa vie en 94
notamment et un peu avant de Jean-Pierre
Elkabach euh qui était lui-même proche
de baladure on se souvient que c'était
la deuxème cohabitation baladure Premier
ministre et et et El cabage qui qui
vient de la droite qui qui a soutenu
giscar quand il était en poste à la
télévision publique à
l'époque et puis à europin je crois je
sais plus exactement où il était en
poste et eurin et et peut-être public en
tout
cas Elkabach devient en 94 patron des
chaînes publiques et de France
Télévision on se souvient de l'affaire
des patates avec les animateurs
producteurs par la suite mais
Jean-Pierre lkabach ça je le raconte
dans mon premier livre sur France
Télévision sur les coulisses de la
télévision publique jean-pierrecabach
momentl à la carte blanche à la fois de
miterran et de baladure pour s'attaquer
au gâteau publicitaire
TF1 c'est-à-dire en faisant monter des
audiences de plus en plus importantes
donc en faisant venir les animateurs
producteurs et en
fait faire venir les patates enfin en
tout cas apporter les patates comment on
les comme les guignoles les appelaent
auprès des animateurs producteurs à
l'époque ça avait une stratégie
d'attaquer l'influence de TF1 et ça
avait été ce que je révèle dans le livre
en partie entre autres ça avait été en
partie accord enfin visé il y avait eu
un accord de mitéran et de baladure pour
que Elkabach attaque TF1 et le gâteau
publicitaire de TF1 parce que c'estes
deux haut responsables politiques et
dieu sait pourtant que Baladur même
Baladur a bénéficié là pour le coup ce
que Péan a présenté comme la
baladurisation de TF1 pendant la
campagne de 95 mais il craignait à
l'époque le pouvoir de TF1 tellement
cette chaîne était extrêmement
importante dans le paysage audiovisuel
français dès l'époque hein il faut
savoir TF1 c'était plus de 50 % du
gâteau publicitaire mais c'était
également une une audience écrasante et
donc la messe du 20ur à l'époque ça
voulait dire quelque chose il y avait
pas encore c'était une autre époque hein
pour la jeune génération qui conna qui a
pas connu cette époque-là et donc avoir
l'influence de TF1 était était cruciale
pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce que là
quand je parlais de chantage on voit
bien que ces forces économiques qui
s'emparent de médias peuvent euh avoir
des moyens de pression sur les
responsables politiques euh et ça veut
dire que les responsables politiques ce
sont pas forcément directement des
marionnettes comme parfois on le
présente un peu rapidement de ses
propriétaires de médiia il y a ils ont
également dans le rapport de force bah
ils ont l'état ils ont le contrôle de
l'État donc tout ça est à faire de
rapport de force mais je reviens à
à donc la fameuse anecdote peut-être
alors la fameuse anecdote elle va être
elle va être on va dire elle va être
double je reviens à je reviens à mon
parcours journalistique
euh donc
euh en 2018 je pars déjà une fois
première fois de Marianne
euh pour les raisons que j'ai évoqué
euh et à l'époque donc on est pendant le
processus de vente et et euh et je ne
sais pas pour quelle raison mais euh
Bruno Roger petit m'appelle et demande à
parce que l'actionnaire de
l'époque me demande de de me mettre en
relation avec l'actionnaire de Marianne
de l'époque qui est également le patron
de l'époque Yve de chaise Martin euh Yve
de chaise Martin grand professionnel de
la presse he qui a été patron du Group
her sang euh et donc il y a un
rendez-vous à l'Élysée et moi j'ai le
retour des deux après de Brunau Roger
petit et de Yv de chz marartin
euh et j'ai le retour des deux et pour
la anecdote c'était peut-être une blague
et d'ailleurs je l'ai prise comme telle
parce que de toute façon ma décision de
partir était était comment dire acté
mais Bruno Roger petit a fait fait a
fait sa pub enfin pas sa pub a fait ma
pub auprès de Yve de chaise Martin
euh en gros quasiment
euh en tout cas dans les version que
j'ai eu de des deux personnes que j'ai
cité euh
en gros ils auraient pas été mécontents
de me voir avoir un poste de direction
je sais pas lequel c'est c'était au
niveau de Marianne racheté par Daniel
kretinski donc à l'époque c'était une
manière en gros
euh de Me de de d'avoir une promotion
mais par la pression on va dire la
pression par l'aide moi je demandais
rien mais non
mais pourquoi je dévoile cette anecdote
c'est que euh c'est parce que je parlais
de jofro le jeune et de Bron petit ojdd
voilà donc là je parle on va dire
d'expérience personnelle euh qu'on ne me
dise pas que ce que j'ai raconté sur
jeoff le jeune est une supposition je
sais comment ça se déroule parfois c'est
la suputation non ça c'est je je je sais
que Bron petit a soutenu mon le jeune et
et et ça explique aussi pourquoi il a
été nommé à la tête du JDD bien
évidemment mais ça reste un un bon
professionnel jeer le je sa ligne
politique qui n'est pas la mienne enfin
ligne politique ligne éditoriale ses
valeurs c'est c'est c'est mais c'est
également ça comment ça se passe
ça se passe également de cette
manière-là
voilà c'est c'est ça peut
être autre autre élément
euh je parlais de Frédéric Michel
Frédéric
Michel je le connaissais pas beaucoup
mais j'ai j'ai été mis en relation par
un un contact commun avant son arrivée à
l'Élysée 6 mois un peu avant
euh puis finalement c'est la surprise il
arrive à l'iser à l'été mais moi
j'arrive à voir la primeur de
l'information que je sors et j'ai pas
l'information au départ par Frédéric
Michel même s'il me l'a confirmé donc
j'ai pu sortir l'information dans la
tribune Frédéric Michel euh il est donc
comme je l'ai dit proche de Boloré de
xaviniel euh et de bien d'autres de
Bernard aussi d'une certain manière il
connaît surtout très bien euh deux
grands producteurs de la place de Paris
Pierre-Antoine cAPTON et Renault levant
Kim Pierre-Antoine cAPTON qui est
coofondateur de media one et surtout de
trisème œil production la boîte de
production qui appartient à media one
qui produit cet avou mais
également c'est dans l'air et euh c'est
l'bdo ça c'est cAPTON cAPTON pigas Niel
ça c'est deux de de de deux
investisseurs et de coactionnaires
Pierre Antoine cAPTON c'est ces
émissions là autre émission du service
public qui donc est externalisé à des
producteurs extérieurs
privés Renault lev Kim grand réalisateur
grand producteur qui a travaillé
beaucoup pour Canal Plus qui était le
producteur du Grand Journal avec Michel
DEIZO c'est des gens qui ont beaucoup de
talent Renault lev team qui s'était
fâché avec Bolloré et qui a quitté et
claqué la porte du groupe Canal Plus et
qui a
trouvé accueil auprès de delphinn et de
France Télévision
euh quelques quelques temps après
l'arrivée de delphinn sous sous François
Hollande à la tête de France Télévision
et Renault lev Kim c'est le producteur
de C ce soir et c'est le producteur de C
ses politiques le dimanche soir sur
France Télévision et et donc Michel
entretient des très bonnes relations
avec ces deux producteurs déjà parce
qu'on l'a su par voie de presse même si
moi j'ai dit l'inverse mais je sais que
l'inverse est vrai euh que
Pierre-Antoine cAPTON en tout cas ne
s'est pas caché d'avoir
accéléré sa sa nomination à l'Élysée de
d'avoir présenté Frédéric Michel au chef
de l'État Pierre-Antoine cAPTON qui a
été décoré par le chef de l'État je ne
sais plus de quelle médaille mais
quelques temps après mais en réalité
c'est Renault lev Kim qui comme je écrit
et je confirme cette information c'est
bien Renault LV Kim d'ailleurs il s'en
cache pas en privé auprès de certains à
France Télévision euh qui me l'ont ça
reste du privé non privé c'est pour dire
que c'était pas public mais en privé
pour dire que j'ai récupéré
l'information Prenn d'une source tierce
un tiers que je n'ai pas voulu là
dévoiler mais je sais qui c'est et je
sais que c'est une personne crédible et
donc
euh et donc c'est bien Renault lev van
Kim qui présente manifestement Frédéric
Michel au chef de l'État d'autant plus
que dès juin 2021 Frédéric Michel qui
travaille pour James Murdock le fils de
REPER Murdock euh ça ça a fait présent
ça a fait partie de la présentation
médiatique de Frédric Michel James
Murdock euh euh donc soutien plutôt de
Biden alors que Murdock historiquement a
plutôt été soutien de Trump puis il s'en
est séparé puis il est revenu en soutien
de Trump puis en ce moment il plus en
soutien de Trump sur le dossier
ukrainien
[Musique]
en juin 2021 James Murdock participe du
Tour de d'un tour de table autour du
média brut média Internet enfin de vidéo
et le média brut donc où d'ailleurs
xaviniel investit rodolp Saad investi et
également je crois François Henry Pinot
le fils de monsieur Pinot de François
Pinot propriétaire de du groupe de luxe
a investi et donc James Murdock a
également investi en juin 2021 dans brut
voilà donc
euh c'est pas des supputations c'est des
faits euh et euh ensuite on a vu
d'ailleurs le président de la République
est interviewé par brut quelques mois
après donc c'est des c'est des bonnes
relations ça ça ça permet de mettre du
de la fluidité euh dans les relations
entre l'Élysée et les médias mais je
parlais de Boloré
euh autre médias public franco-allemand
é euh 28 minutes euh la proprié é de 28
minutes c'est le Group baniget qui
appartient à un courb dans lequel
Bernard Arnaud et Vincent boloret
investi ça se sait peu les gens qui
regarde croit voir une émission interne
d'art c'est également en fait c'est
baniga qui produit donc en
réalité 28 minutes et si si si je suis
un peu provocateur et un peu l'émission
cousine de hanuna
voilà c'est très provocateur oui c'est
la mission cousine pour les vieux c'est
ça c'est pas le même ça ça sad reste pas
au même public ça pas la même ligne
éditoriale on voit bien c'est pas la
même ligne éditoriale reste que c'est le
même j'allais dire trivialement c'est le
même business voilà et et et et voilà et
donc ça c'est c'est intéressant à à
connaître et à savoir parce que ça se
sait peu et ça se dit peu alors que ces
émissions là aujourd'hui notamment avec
Internet font la puie et le BE temps en
ce qui concerne l'opinion parce qu'on
parle beaucoup des chaînes d'information
dit d'information parce que c'est plutôt
des chaînes de débat que d'information
et justement quand je dis ces chaînes-là
participent de l'opinion et parti parce
que c'est le c'est comment dire c'est le
carburant beaucoup à ces à ces extraits
vidéos c'est le carburant au réseaux
sociaux parce que même si les gens sur
les réseaux sociaux ont pris le pouvoir
par euh les les prises de position même
si après on peut avoir plein de
questions sur les algorithmes et bien
sûr euh la transparence des algoritmes
voilà x musk et voilà et tout ça et
compagnie et donc sur la manipulation de
de de au final de de de ce qui est promu
comme information ou plutôt comme prise
de position sur les réseaux sociaux euh
il faut jamais oublier qu'une partie du
carburant c'est les vidéos et et et les
et les flux vidéos et les extraits
vidéos parfois principalement issu de
ces programmesl et et le le le CES
programmesl notamment sur la politique
on le voit euh c'est ces émissionsl où
maintenant les responsables politiques
se bousculent euh au portillon pour être
interviewé à tel point d'ailleurs que
une émission que j'ai pas cité qui est
quotidien et euh donc qui est aussi un
producteur privé mais allié à au groupe
TF1 parce que c'était MC ils avaient
annoncé cette année qu'il ne recevait
plus de responsable politique une
semaine de semaines après ils ont reçu
François Hollande ils ont dit que
c'était exceptionnel mais en tout cas
ils ont fait plutôt je crois qu'ils ont
conservé ce choix-là dans dans les dans
les émissions qu'on suivi reste que
quand c'est pas des politiques c'est des
leaders d'opinion c'est des sondeurs
c'est des commentateurs politiques
notamment des journalistes politiques et
donc ils ont ils donnent accès à une
typologie de
journaliste et ça c'est important y
compris par rapport à mon travail
d'enquête c'est que ces émissionsl sont
des émissions quand même principalement
d'fanttainment de mélange des genes et
ces émissions euh qui traitent de
l'actualité parfois très bien avec des
des journalistes qui sont talentueux
certains très talentueux
mais il ils ont un pouvoir sur les gens
qu'ils invitent ou pas et ils n'invitent
pas tout le monde et par ailleurs c'est
magnifeste en fonction des lignes
éditoriales d'ailleurs c'est la liberté
d'une certaine manière enfin chose que
nous tout le monde lité c'est la liberté
pas totalement parce que les règles de
l'arcom excsa c'est justement d'assurer
le pluralisme de audiovisuel alors il
faut faut savoir ça c'est une évolution
ancienne qui vient des États-Unis où
effectivement Fox News et tous les
miliard les médias très proche de
l'ultra droite américaine a a poussé
pour casser ce cadre là qui existait
déjà aux États-Unis de d'équilibre des
prises de parole politique ou de
sensibilité politique dans les émissions
et ça c'est des règlements qu'on qu' on
été pétés par enfin par par force de
lobbying à l'époque par par par Fox News
et tous ces médias là et et tout le
débat est on voit on le voit bien avec
Boloré tout le débat est arrivé en
France bon alors ça plaît à certains ça
plaît à ça déplaît à d'autres sauf que
là-dedans tout le monde dit liberté
liberté notamment groupe Boré par
exemple mais aucune de ces émissions euh
ou très rarement font état des des
enquêtes journalistiques des des
journalistes dit d'enquête ou
d'investigation et ça c'est un élément
extrêmement important à prendre en
compte c'est-à-dire c'est un tu parlais
de censure vous parliez de
censure on est on c'est une forme de
censure c'est-à-dire de l'information
c'est-à-dire que les informations
compliquées on parlait de l'affaire
colère c'est un dossier qui c'est un
dossier très c'est un dossier très
complexe j'ai essayé de le résumer en
peu de mots en étant précis mais mais
c'est des dossiers où il y a des des
enjeux considérabl en réalité et c'est
des dossiers que les Français qui sont
fatigués qui n'ont pas le temps de parce
que s'informer ça demande un effort ça
demande du temps et pour avoir du temps
parfois il faut de l'argent mais donc
bien évidemment ils sont fatigués ils
allument leur télé de soir ils regardent
les réseaux sociaux et donc je dis pas
que c'est bien enfin que c'est pas bien
enfin mais bon c'est comme ça bon
euh et bien ils ont pas accès à à à ces
informations parce que tout à l'heure je
parlais des 200000 abonnés de miaapart
deuxè site internet d'information
numérique en France c'est considérable
pour l'inventure de meddiap sur le plan
économique mais c'est peinut sur
l'ensemble du marché médiatique français
c'est peinut et donc y compris leurs
enquêtes moi je pense à une grande
communicante comme Anne Mo qui m'avait
confié
notamment grande communicante du 440
donc que j'ai rencontré pour le pour le
livre que je suis en train de faire sur
le monde des affaires et elle m'a elle
m'avait
ça montrait également comment dire la la
forme de relativisme aujourd'hui de ces
de ces forces économiques relativisme au
sens il participe au relativisme parce
que c'était ah bah si c'est dans médiia
part c'est pas grave parce que c'est un
modèle fermé et donc ça se diffuse pas
et donc ça peut se diffuser il dirait
pas ça oui mais parce que Sarko oui mais
encore Sarkozi dirait pas ça sauf que
media part le très bien le procès actuel
sur Sarkozi Libye soupçon de financement
la campagne de Nicolas Sarkozi par la
Libye et libien est sous-traité par les
grands médias et par les télévisions ça
a été dit encore
récemment plein de grandes enquête de la
presse écrite même hors méia part sont
très
difficilement mis en boîte au sens mis à
l'avant en avant par soit les plateaux
de débat que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure
soit les les émissions d'information
grand public très rarement il y a des
exceptions hein je vais les citer
d'ailleurs et heureusement parce que
c'est des c'est des gens qui qui qui
m'ont aidé et qui qui et qui ont diffusé
mes enquêtes mais en fait ça se compte
sur les doigts d'une main et et et donc
là-dedans donc la question c'est la
diffusion de ces enquêtes là parce que
il y a il y a un conseil à la fin de
l'émission C'est jeune génération
mais là je là je vais donner un conseil
aux gens qui qui me suivent déjà depuis
pas mal de temps et qui sont pas saoulés
par rapport à tout ce que je dis mais
euh euh c'est les meilleurs c'est
l'élite voilà ouais c'est ça ou mais bon
euh oui il faut faire l'effort de
s'informer mais il y a un autre truc
aussi il faut s'emparer des informations
c'estd il faut les diffuser le plus
possible sur les réseaux sociaux les
informations les enquêtes de
journalistes les enquêtes où il y a des
faits vidé partager les par et il faut
et il faut également les partis
politiques les associations les
contrepouvoirs l'ensemble de la vie
démocratique d'un pays doivent s'emparer
des informations et des Enes trop tard
c'est pas trop tard quand on a une
population qui est stressé qui ser qui
s'approche d'une trisème guerre mondiale
qui est en catatonie
émotionnelleat c'est un enjeu
démocratique majeur je c'est presque un
SOS que je je lance j'allais dire je
j'interviewis à une consœur Arian
lavriilleux qui a été convoqué par la
DGSI sur des enquêtes qu'elle a dévoilé
sur des vente d'armes françaises en
Égypte et en MoyenOrient bon et on
parlait de ça on par je parlais ensemble
avec elle de la de la difficulté de
faire diffuser des des scandales de
presse aujourd'hui dans l'univers de
l'économie médiatique d'aujourd'hui
c'est très compliqué est-ce que c'est
pas fait à dessin c'est-à-dire saturer
saturer l'esprit des gens ah bah oui
bien sûr mais ça c'est le boulot c'est
le boulot de Frédéric Michel de bon je
petit sur la partie politique à l'Élysée
de des grandes agences de communication
et d'influence il sature de bruit
médiatique l'ensemble y compris parfois
de la production de la presse en général
mais il sature de bruit médiatique ce
qu'on appelle le storytelling ce qu'on
appelle le le cadrage des événements il
raconte une histoire pour occuper
l'espace pour occuper les esprits et
pendant ce temps-là on parle pas des
dossiers qui fâchent ou des dossiers qui
pourraient fâcher euh par exemple
euh dans dans
euh je donne un exemple qui est pas un
scandale qui est pas une affaire mais je
donne par exempleexemple de de DF et du
nucléaire et du nouveau nucléaire bon je
fais une
enquête qui paraît dans la tribune sur
le site internet de La Tribune en
décembre 2019 et qui parle des
difficultés industrielles de la filière
nucléaire y compris dans les problèmes
liés aux soudures par exemple des
réacteur nucléaire est lié justement au
fait qu'il y a plus de soudeur que il y
a plus de personnel formé que il y a une
rupture générationnelle 2 3 ans après
énorme crise euh àedf parce que il y a
une partie du parc qui est euh euh pas
au point euh en terme de maintenance qui
est totalement sous contrainte la France
qui d'habitude euh la la la qui trouve
pas de soudeur on doit faire appel à des
soudeurs américains la France est
obligée d'importer de l'énergie alors
qu'elle était généralement exportatrice
avec ses 56 ou 58 réacteurs non 56
réacteurs nucléaair maintenant
aujourd'hui moment où nous
ennu c'est un tout petit exemple qui
force à l'huminité d'une certaine
manière c'est je fais quand même quatre
pages parce que c'était il y avait
encore la tribune papier je fais qure
pages sur ce dossier là alors c'est la
tribune c'est pas le monde donc ça a
beaucoup moins de poids j'en suis bien
conscient mais reste
que les gens souvent me demandent par
rapport à mes enquêtes sur les pouvoir
et le pouvoir macronisme mais pas que
mais parce que j'ai fait bien d'autres
choses que Macron mais c'est est-ce que
vous avez eu des menaces est-ce que vous
avez eu des pression ça peut exister ça
est-ce qu'on t'a fait sauter ton compte
en bque voilà non mais non ça ça ça
c'est très rare en fait mais ça peut
exister mais c'est pas ça l'essentiel le
plus facile c'est l'invisibilisation et
la marginalisation dans le bruit à la
fois dans le bruit mais en fait aussi
très concrètement euh parce que euh
d'ailleurs il y a plus grandchose à
faire parce que effectivement tout le
système profite au buzz facile profite
euh à la petite polémique à la petite
phrase euh à ces émissions de plateau
qui donnent 5 10 minutes euh par exemple
je donne un autre exemple qui me
concerne après après je je vais je vais
parler un peu vas-y voilà je je je donne
un autre exemple qui me concerne pas
mais
bon et c'est des confrères qui bien bien
d'autres capitaux en main parce que
c'est des confrères du monde c'est des
grands porteurs du monde qu'on
travailler sur Macron d'ailleurs je
parlais de Gérard det et Fabrice Lom
donc ils ont fait un livre sur Macron
ils ont été invités sur les télés c'est
des bons clients ils ont été invités
partout mais là ils font un livre
autrement plus intéressant de mon point
de vue en tout cas sur la pandémie où il
dévoile tout le contenu de l'enquête
confidentielle de la Cour de Justice de
la République sur la la la la comment
dire la gestion de l'État la mauvaise
gestion de l'État par rapport à la
pandémie certes ils sont limités à la
question des masques des des matériel de
protection mais enfin il faut faut se
souvenir de la panique que ça a été en
2020 de s'apercevoir que la France 5e
puissance enfin plus 5e puissance mais
membre du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies était même pas capable de
fournir des masques de protection même
pas à la population mais également aux
policiers aux infirmiers aux pompiers
euh aux gens qui étaient aux première
loge aux médecins c'est c'est quand même
une histoire folle on a un peuock de Mas
d parce que eux ils font gaffe voilà et
donc
euh le bouquin là leur dernier livre
euh je sais plus comment il s'appelle
euh bon font état de cette enquête làà
il ça fourmie de documents bon c'est
juste une partie de tout ce qui devrait
être dit et surtout enquêter c'est
tellement énorme ce dossier covid
mais donc je les ai
invité au poste médiat de David dufine
où je fais des interviews de de de
journalistes euh dans une émission qui
s'appelle la boîte noire petite émission
de gauche c'est ça pour les autres ultra
gauche parenthèse j'ouv une
parenthèse s'il te plaît juste juste
juste un petit point juste un petit
point et donc
là dans dans ce dans dans ce cadre là je
je j'ai demandé j'ai invité Fabrice et
j'ai demandé
mais est-ce que vous avez été invités
sur les plateaux télé et ils ont pas été
invités sur les plateaux télé ils ont eu
des matinales ils ont eu des radios mais
ils ont pas eu des plateaux télé il faut
les emmener ici du temps et donc donc
c'est un exemple qui me concerne pas
mais ça me concerne aussi parce que je
sais très bien les émissions dont je
parlais je suis pas invité sur ces
émissions là et je suis pas invité même
pas parce que je seraai de gauche de
droite je suis de gauche tout le monde
le sait mais c'est même pas par rapport
à ça c'est parce que je fait travail
d'information il y a il y a une amie
communicante qui a essayé enfin petite
communicante mais qui qui a qui essayé
de m'aider en disant mais j'adore tes
livres il faut que je t'aideon et donc
qui a essayé de m'inviter sur une
émission euh la réponse qui a été je
citerai pas l'émission pour pas pour
mettre pas mettre en en porte à FAO là
la la la la la le contact l'ami et donc
la la réponse ça a été ah non mais
enveld il est
ingérable sur les plateaux télé pourtant
je suis très gentil je réponds aux
question euh je suis moins long
qu'ici je le précise
euh et en fait je lui dis mais ingérable
je lui fais cette réponse là et et je
lui dis puis il y a aussi des gens
différentes sensibilités au différents
médias qui sont invités ah non non mais
ingérable dans le sens où il serait pas
capable de traiter des sujets et des
informations que tu délivres
bon c'est la réponse qui a été faite
voilà c'estàd qu'en gros oui pour
inviter un journaliste qui fait des
enquêtes il faut également connaître un
peu les dossiers du journaliste et ces
enquêtes là et ces dossiersl et donc
pour apporter la contradiction les
précisions il faut aussi un minimum
travailler bon donc là je je reste
gentil ou dans le fémisme parce que bon
bien évidemment c'est pas li que ça je
cite avant des
émissions
qui m'ont aidé des grands médias oui
mais là des grands médias oui oui oui
non mais je vois bien sûr là bah si j'ai
accepté l'invitation c'est que il y a
des raisons c'est parce que j'ai plus
beaucoup de Canau de de de
d'information et si tu en avais tu
serais quand même venu je reprends la
parole les médias de droite disent que
les journalistes de gauche ou les
personnes de gauche viennent pas
s'exprimer chez eux ah bah je vais
répondre très simplement moi je suis de
gauche hein tout le monde le sait je
travailler pour des journaux de gauche
un témoignage chrétien je vais pas faire
un dessin enfin si je peux le rappeler
témoignage chrétien était un grand
journal qui s'est battu pour
l'indépendance de l'Algérie donc dans
les années 60 donc voilà ça ça situe
mais
euh et encore une fois ça n'a pas de
conséquence sur mes enquêtes j'ai
travaillé sur la gauche la droite j'ai
et justement c'est peut-être pour ça que
mais mais voilà de toute façon j'ai j'ai
j'ai un j'ai j'ai j'ai un j'ai parmi les
gens qui ont qui achètent mes livres qui
connaissent mon travail qui me lisent
j'ai des gens de toutes les sensibilités
dans mes contacts et mes sources j'ai
des gens de toutes les sensibilités de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
parle à tout le monde c'est mon boulot
de journaliste c'est normal mais euh
c'est une bonne question aussi parce que
bizarrement même Boloré quand il était
contre Macron parce que les les les
macronistes ba parce qu'il y a des
macronistes intéressants mais on va dire
les gens qui réagissent un peu au quart
de tour dès qu'on apporte une
information qui pourrait déplaire au
chef de l'État
euh euh donc euh qu'est-ce que je
voulais dire oui me dépeigne comme un
antimacronistme primaire et parce que
j'ai fait des enquêtes sur Emmanuel
Macron bon je rappelle quand même que
l'ambigu monsieur Macron le premier
livre que j'ai fait qui était le premier
livre enfin le premier livre que j'ai
fait sur Macron qui était le premier
livre sur Macron j'ai interview Emmanuel
Macron dans le livre he tout le monde
l'oublie
euh bon
euh qu'est-ce que je voulais dire les
médias de gauche les médias de droite
les journalistes de gauche les
journalist je par Boré quand il enquêtes
les les émissions de Boloré enfin si on
parle des émissions de B quand ils
étaient contre Macron enfin là
actuellement ils sont contre Macron et
puis avec très fortement et notamment
sur Russie et Ukraine et d'ailleurs il y
a un paradoxe à ça je le dirai juste
après comme quoi tout est relatif d'une
C manière ou en tout cas tout est en
nuance et en complexité mais je dirais
juste après les Boloré euh enfin les
émissions du groupe Boloré on va être
gentil mais ils m'ont jamais invité ils
m'ont invité une fois je suis allé une
fois sur ces news et c'était pour parler
de mon mon livre l'emprise mais c'est
tout ils m'ont jamais
invité donc le discours de la liberté et
deux on est pluraliste c'est facile
c'est vendeur mais en fait c'est aussi
la difficulté d'aujourd'hui et qui est
lié également à la responsabilité pas
uniquement des journalistes mais la
responsabilité on parlait des Français
qui sont fatigués c'est que il y a un
principe de cohérence sur le plan
psychologique quasiment aujourd'hui qui
fait qu'effectivement les gens avec les
algorithmes et compagnie ont tendance
euh à se regrouper entre convaincus et à
consommer des médias où ils sont déjà
convaincus il y a un terme qui s'appelle
un une bulle de filtre voilà et donc et
donc il y a une il y a une fragmentation
des publics et des médias en opposition
à Boloré le service public euh on dit
toujours qu'il y a que des mecs de
gauche qui se baladent sur le service
public bah je suis pas invité non plus
enfin j'ai été invité pour être précis
j'ai été invité à deux reprises depuis
oui parce que pour être clair en fait
hein euh pour être très clair euh je
avant 2019 même quand je fais l'ambigu
monsieur Macron
euh je suis invité euh j'ai je me suis
même retrouvé sur le plateau du du Grand
Journal de maena birenben quand elle
travaillait pour le groupe Boloré elle
en est partie en mauvais terme au bout
d'un an elle a gagné face à Boloré bon
mais j'étais invité sur BFM TV sur LCI
j'étais invité sur ittélévision je crois
je sais plus enfin mais depuis l'ambigum
depuis le grand manipulateur en avril
2019 je suis beaucoup moins invité donc
quand je parlais de marginalisation
c'est juste un constat euh mar ation
professionnelle d'invisibilisation et ça
bien évidemment c'est pas uniquement
parce que je suis ingérable parce que
j'ai des informations sur un plateau
télé c'est pas uniquement parce que on
croit que je fais trop long euh parce
que sur des plateaux de
télévision habituel je sais faire cours
euh de toute façon c'est factuel les les
les les les France Télévision m'a invité
trois fois euh depuis 2019 deux deux
trois trois quatre fois deux petites
reprises sur France Info la chaîne
d'information euh je crois trois fois et
euh une fois à C à dire unemion qui
existe plus qui était avancée dans l'air
donc invité par allez media one voilà et
c'était Mélanie taravant qui fait c'est
médiatique d'ailleurs l'émission de
média sur France 5 qui m'a invité pour
parler 15 minutes de mon livre c'est
tout
euh ça et alors je mettrai un bémol ça
c'est pour les émissions de plateau le
bémol va arriver
mais je voulais rajouter autre chose
avant l'homme davait pareil ah non
beaucoup plus invité beaucoup plus quand
même mais ils sont non moins et pas pas
de télé et pas de gros plateau télé en
tout cas depuis 2019 les seuls plateau
de télévision donc en deh ces émissions
là sur l'audiovisuel public mais il y a
des il y a une exception quand même mais
justement c'est c'est pas des émissions
de d'information de débat enfin c'est
des émissions d'information mais
d'enquête mais les les les les les
seuls qui ensuite m'invite notamment
depuis 2022 c'est Public Sénat France
24 voilà Public Sénat France 24 c'estàd
par exemple depuis la dissolution là
j'ai été invité sur Public Sénat et
France 24 c'est tout voilà euh il y a
meilleure exposition
médiatique c'est deux très bonnes
chaînes c'est deux très bonnes chaînes
et d'ailleurs j'y vais avec plaisir euh
Thomas HUG Public Sénat c'était très
sympathique très intéressant et on a
parlé de la dissolution et j'essayie
d'expliquer pourquoi Macron av est amené
à dissoudre et et et pourquoi Macron
pensa allait faire d'ailleurs ce qui
s'est passé c'est-à-dire n'allait pas
nommer euh un premier ministre de gauche
ou en tout cas de de majorité de gauche
enfin non majorité parce qu'il y a plus
de majorité mais en tout cas euh bon la
gauche qui arrivé en premier opposition
voilà euh et euh donc Public Sénat
France
24 voilà et et après euh dans et et et
alors méia Boloré là pour le coup jamais
alors c'est pas que je le réclame hein
parce que bien évidemment je j'aurais
rien à [__] dans dans le cierc d'anuna
on est d'accord mais mais mais c'est
quand même mais quand ils disent on
invite mais on on invite qui voilà on
invite des gens qui
polémiquent qui font du
buzz même quand ils sont à gauche qui
sont grande gueule d'ailleurs même
parfois ils sont chroniqueurs hein on a
vu Raquel garido là apportter la
contradiction sur LCI maintenant à à
Luis Sarkozi bon c'est des responsables
politiques mais c'est des c'est des
chroniqueurs ils sont payés
vraisemblablement enfin à vérifier mais
je crois qu'ils sont payé euh le le le
donc là on n'est pas dans le champ de
l'information on est dans le champ du
spectacle et après mais parce que je
commence à fatiguer jeen mets une excuse
euh et bien après il y a les émissions
qui m'ont invité c'est aussi le service
public audiovisuel quand même je le
soulligne c'est affairirees sensible sur
France Inter émission de
dossier politico financiers parfois
d'histoire des coulisses de la 5e
République qui qui avait remplacé
l'émission monsieur X il y a longtemps
affair sensible Fabrice drouel voilà
invité plusieurs fois y compris sur le
dossier Alexis ca
euh juste après la mise en examen de
d'Alexis coller une demi-heure
d'interview c'est Fabrice drouel en
télévision parce que maintenant ils sont
en télévision je crois qu'ils ont gardé
la l'émission en tout cas j'espère et
sur cette émission là c'était sur
justement Nicolas Sarko c'était le
nucléaire français la corruption dans le
nucléaire français euh
EDF et c'était sur un documentaire sur
la syndicaliste Maine
carnet syndicaliste qui a été agressé
dans le cadre de ses fonctions la CFDT à
chareva euh
et que la justice a comment dire a a
enfin film alors il y a eu un alors
justement c'est intéressant donc Maine a
souffert de la justice parce que elle a
doublement souffert Maine carnet parce
que donc les les la première enquête de
gendarmerie et le premier procès l'ont
présenté comme une fabulatrice euh
finalement tous les faits
journalistiques et même il y a eu je
crois alors il y a pas eu reconnaissance
totale du fait que elle était totalement
innocente et d'ailleurs elle se bat
toujours par rapport à ça mais euh en
tout cas elle a elle a le la première
condamnation ils sont revenus sur la
première condamnation elle avait bien é
elle a bien été agressée violée hein en
l'occurrence attaché voilà elle le
décrit voilà c'est les enquêtes d'une
consceur que je connais bien qui
Caroline Michel à l'OPS euh qui a donc
fait plusieurs papiers sur les lien
entre le nucléaire chinois et le
nucléaire français et lien de corruption
parce que c'était ce dont c'était ça ce
dont il s'agissait et Maine carnet a
fait partie on va dire des lanceuses
d'alertes sur des contrats entre la
France et la Chine où la question de la
sécurité nationale n'était pas respectée
en terme de transfert de technologie
notamment
et et donc sur le plateau de famri Noë
après le documentaire il y avait Maine
carnet il y avait moi et j'ai pu dire
des
choses notamment où je parlait de
l'intermédiaire qui est aujourd'hui dans
au procès de la Libye fameux
intermédiaire Alexandre joury
euh donc je présentais des choses par
rapport à ça cette émission qui est
passée sur le service public Fabrice
drouel affaires sensiblebl les autres
émissions c'est secret d'info aussi
Radio France c'est l'émission de la
cellule d'investigation de Radio France
dirigée aujourd'hui par benoî clomba et
euh ensuite qui était avant au manettees
Jacques Monin
euh et eux à plusieurs reprises m'ont
invité euh et on et ont relayé mes
enquêtes y compris la à Marianne l'année
dernière une enquête de corruption
autour de d'Aéroport de Paris et de la
Libye
euh quasiment un quart d'heure 20
minutes d'interview et le les derniers
qui relaent mes enquêtes dans gros les
grands médias euh mais là je parle pas
de la presse écrite parce que j'ai quand
même été soutenu en presse écrite
notamment le monde mais euh ça a été euh
complément d'enquête de Tristan Wallex
alors pas en plateau parce qu'ils font
des documentaires mais régulièrement ils
m'ont interviewé un documentaire je
voudrais qu'on parle d'Atos oui Atos
quoi Atos bien portos et Ramis qu'est-ce
que c'est
Atos alors Athos c'est à la fois un
dossier à première vue incompréhensible
et très simple déjà qui est-ce qui
dirigeit àau c'est quelle époque alors
jusqu'en euh 2018-29 je crois 2019
c'était Thierry Breton qui a ensuite
passé à la Commission européenne qui a
fait énormément d'acquisitions
euh donc la la boîte a grossi a grossi a
grossi acquisition malheureuse
maintenant tous les analystes le disent
euh des gens sur la place considèrent
qu'il a
mis à plat la la boîte finalement parce
que c'était en faisant des acquisitions
extérieures la rentabilité était pas
assurée pour plein de raisons petite
remarque
d'importance mais juste factuelle
euh Thierry Breton donc quand il était
patron d'os a racheté des
activités en Allemagne à Siemens je
crois dans souenir les activités
informatiques qui se sont révélé très
hasardeuses en terme de rentabilité
notamment ce qu'on appelle l'infogérant
c'est l'
serviceinatique aux entreprises en gros
c'est la sous-traitance de gestion de
des des réseaux et des parcs
informatiques des
entreprises ce deal a été fait sur les
conseils aussi d'Emmanuel Macron à la
banque rochield avec grégire shertoock
on prend une petite commission quand on
fait ce genre de chose ou pas oui oui
oui bien sûr enfin quand les deal quand
les deals sont réalisés il y a il y a
des commissions qui s'élève de quoi
c'est un pouem un gros pouem 1 %
10%% j'ai plus en tête les pourcentages
mais c'est 1 2 3 % je crois un truc
comme ça j'ai plus mais après à chez
rothchield c'est une comment dire le il
y a un pot global avec tous les les
banquiers et c'est en fonction du du
grade euh du banquier et une répartition
inégalitaire enfin voilà enfin c'est pas
parce que vous avez travaillé vous avez
réussi le D la petite échelle que vous
gagnez le pactol en fait c'est les c'est
les plus gros banquiers de la de la de
l'entreprise qui récupère le plus de de
fis sur sur les opérations plus de de
pourcentage sur opération donc ça
c'était pour l'anecdote mais
effectivement euh j'avais interviewé
Thierry Breton dans l'ambigu monsieur
Macron parce que je connaissais cet
épisode là et donc euh je lui avais
demandé qu'est-ce qu'il pensait à
l'époque de d'Emmanuel Macron voilà et
donc bon je passe les détails il a euh
il a passé euh les rennes dans
l'entreprise en 2019 il y a eu toute une
succession de de de de de comment dire
de nouvelle direction la boîte s'est
croulé enfin ça s'est très mal passé
donc moi j'ai je me suis j'ai commencé à
enquêter sur Athos début
2023 et à l'époque la presse économique
avait déjà traité du dossier depuis à
peu près 6 mois parce que était présenté
à la presse économique un plan de
cission de
l'entreprise où il fallait en gros il y
avit les équipes a il y avait les
équipes B il fallait donc sissonner
entreprise pour vendre vendre un bout en
gros c'était ça le projet euh le projet
dans me souvenir c'était donc le le
patron de l'époque Bertrand meunier qui
l'a mis en
place euh et donc moi je fais un premier
papier en février
2023 pour expliquer en quoi c'est une
hérésie industrielle de découper la
boîte en deux à l'époque euh bon je fais
ça à l'époque sur ma
newsletter euh qui est sur le la
plateforme substac euh qui est pour
l'instant a accès libre c'est
marcendevel.substac.com je sais pas si
l'adresse et et donc je fais un long
papier d'enquête pour expliquer aussi
les les les raisons de la sensibilité du
dossier que c'est pas seulement un
dossier financier mais c'est également
un dossier stratégique parce que dans
Atos il y a pas que de l'infogérance il
y a également de la cybersécurité et il
y a surtout un reste des programmes
historiques industriels et informatiqu
de l'État colbertiste de la grande
époque il y a la division BDS et la
division BDS c'est l'origine enfin c'est
l'héritière des activités du groupe Bull
qui était
donc le l'un des rares groupe
informatique
français et spécialisé dans les super
calculateurs les énormes ordinateurs
alors oui c'est vrai la France n'a plus
de souveraineté sur les
puces électronique les plus performantes
sur les microprocesseurs plus exactement
même si y a ST Microelectronics qui
produit donc groupe franco-italien qui
produit des puces mais il faut savoir
que c'est pas les puces les plus
performantes c'est des d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu' St MRO Electronics
actuellement est plutôt en difficulté
euh
et parce que ils vendent beaucoup de
puces pour l'industrie automobile c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont en difficulté mais
St microélectroni fait quand même les
les les puces qui font par exemple la
reconnaissance faciale des iPhon donc
quand même c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal reste que sur le marché c'est les
Chinois les
Américains les Coréens euh Taiwan aussi
quand je dis chinois qui sont numéro
1 en terme de de de de de compétitivité
et de et de et de et de technologie même
si en Europe on dispose au Pays-Bas
d'une entreprise clé qui est
l'entreprise euh des machines qui
gravent les puces bon ça je mets ça au
sur le côté bref je reviens un bull Bull
même s'il disposent pas dans leur chaîne
de fabrication des des microprocesseurs
les plus performants enfin ils utilisent
des microprocesseur de l'étranger c'est
eux qui font les gros super calculateurs
et ça ça a deux applications enfin
notamment très sensible aujourd'hui
notamment d'un côté
tout ce qui
est
modélisation simulation notamment
concernant la dissuasion
nucléaire et donc c'est un actif de
souveraineté considérable et aujourd'hui
toujours souveraineté je vais expliquer
pourquoi ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle mais pas l'intelligence
artificielle pour le grand public mais
l'intelligence artificielle également a
des implications de
défense et donc c'est ces activités là
qui sont sont les plus stratégiquesok
sain de drone et G alors oui justement
mais je vais revenir dessus parce que
c'est très important y compris par
rapport à l'actualité récente
euh
donc à l'époque quand je fais le papier
en février 2023 c'est parce que les
milieux de Défense français notamment
sont très inquiets de la situation chez
Atos de la situation actionnariale voilà
et notamment du côté de l'État il y
a il y a notamment l'entourage de de
l'entourage et les genses dedans je sais
d'une direction très stratégique qui est
liée au commissariat l'énergie atomique
mais qui est la branche militaire du
commissariat l'énergie atomique qui est
la direction des applications
militaires la dame qui est en fait
chargé de la dissuision nucléaire
française et il faut savoir depuis
Chirac les derniers essais à Mura je
rappelle que donc pour créer pour
moderniser la force de dissuasion
nucléaire donc créer de nouveaux
missiles nouvelles ogives
miniaturiserogif parce que ça c'est
actuellement un des enjeux pour et bien
maintenant ça procède pas par des tests
grandeur nature c'est par des
simulations numériques c'est ça les
enjeux les enjeux sont considérables on
a l'impression que la diff nucléaire
c'est àquis pas du tout dissuasion
nucléaire c'est quelque chose qui évolue
et on le voit on va en parler peut-être
peut-être après parce que les méthodes
d'interception évoluent et parce que en
fait il n'y a dissuasion que s'il y a
équilibre stratégique ça on va revenir
parce que là depuis de semaines et 3
semaines il y a tout et n'importe quoi
qui sont racontés sur les plateaux de
télévision et et et par les et parfois
par des responsables
politiques parce que on est dans une
situation grave du du point de vue de la
dissuasion nucléaire très grave en terme
de souveraineté et d'indépendance pas
que en terme de d'effectivité de la
dissuasion en terme d'effectivité de
dissuision en terme de prolifération
nucléaire on on est dans une situation
extrêmement grave j'en parlerai juste
après je finirai je vais finir sur Atos
assez rapidement même si ben je vous
renverrai à mes articles pour le coup
mais donc je fais une série d'articles
Atos euh et donc euh pour expliquer que
on peut pas si découper notamment la
boîte en deux je la fais très vite parce
que déjà il y a des clients dans
plusieurs branches du groupe donc
commercialement même ça n'a aucun sens
de diviser la en deux parce que il y a
des clients historiques d'Atos qui se
retrouvent écartelés entre de deux parce
que ce n'est que un montage financier
c'est pas un montage industriel
économique et c'est un montage financier
qui est fait notamment par la boîte
conseil la les banquiers conseil d'Atos
c'est rothchield et notamment Grégoire
shertock qui a travaillé aussi avec
Emmanuel Macron bon et euh et donc je
décris ça par le menu les coulisses et
donc c'est un c'est un papier au moment
où le groupe abus s'intéresse au groupe
atthos nous ditons sur les gazettes
économiqu et où les milieux économiques
les milieux industriels français de la
défense sont très dans le soupçon
enfin la perspective de voir Airbus
racheter là pour le coup BDS les les
activités plus stratégiques parce que
les activités militaires ce qui reste
des activités militaires d'Airbus c'est
des activités
allemandes et donc pas françaises donc
là les les milieux de défense considèent
qu'il y a un enjeu de souveraineté not
notamment parce que derrière il y a la
question de la dissuasion bon dans le
papier j'explique que l'opération avec
Airbus ne se fera pas en gros 2 mois
après c'est ce qui finalement arrive
Airbus abandonne des négociations avec
Athos mais après je vais je peux pas
résumer parce que il y a eu plein de
rebondissement encore une fois je
renvoie aux articles mais après la la le
plan de cission a continué alors petite
précision aujourd'hui par les nouvelles
équipes de direction de de d'Atos euh le
plan est abandonné d'ailleurs de cission
mais on on éventuellement on est face à
un un un projet de démentalement parce
que c'est passé au tribunal de commerce
à l'automne et donc la boîte va très
très mal et bon mais euh à l'époque il y
a deux acteurs qui s'intéressent à Athos
Daniel
kretinski voilà et un plus petit Pousset
David Layani et kretinski n'a pas du
tout investi dans le numérique jusqu'à
présent et s'intéresse à la à la partie
la soit-disant la moin stratégique tech
Foundation enfin ce qu'ils ont appelé
tech Foundation et donc là il y a plein
d'épisodes et de polémiqu le dossier
s'est un peu politisé au cours de l'été
2023 non à partir de à partir de 2024 je
crois en fait mais au cours de l'été
2023 j'annonce
le fait que il y a le deal se fait
avectinski en fait je fais plusieurs
papiers
voilà voilà
je là c'est après c'est trop long il y a
trop d'épisodes reste que je reviens à
la sensibilité d'Atos pour faire Simp la
dissuion auss as la dissuasion
après sur l'intelligence artificielle
pourquoi c'est
important parce que en
fait même si Bull ne produit pas les
puces les plus performantes c'est quand
même eux qui savent faire les super
calculateurs et il y a pas d'autres
groupes européens capable de faire ça et
donc l'intelligence artificielle a
besoin de ces énormes super
calculateurs et en fait il y a un enjeu
de défense comme je l'ai dit sur
intelligence artificielle c'est sur
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
milieu de la défense ça permettre la
guerre du futur enfin la guerre de
maintenant en réalité potentiellement
c'est-à-dire la coordination de tous les
moyens dans l'air et l'espace entre les
drones les avions de chasse et sur la
numérisation et les troup au sol c'est
une sorte de grand jeu vidéo pour les
forces armées euh peut-être la
robotisation dans 20 30 ans pour
certains éléments mais et notamment
l'enjeu de la défense aujourd'hui c'est
l'espace parce que toute cette
coordination là donc qui sera permise
par l'IA l'intelligence artificielle et
par des super calculateurs sera permise
également par des constellations de
satellite et là l'Europe est totalement
à poil totalement à poil et ces derniers
mois encore dossier stratégique mais qui
fait quelques papiers dans la presse
économique
seulement mais seulement donc ce n'est
qu'une dossier spécialiste alors que
c'est un dossier mais monstrueux sur le
plan stratégique et politique j'y viens
c'est que vous l'avez peut-être entendu
il y a quelques jours enfin quelques
semaines François Baayou quand il s'est
déplacé à maotte pour les les événements
dramatique à Mayotte il a fait une
sortie enfin je crois que c'est
Baou j'espère ne pas faire de
d'imprécision mais il me semble bien en
en en faisant référence à Starlink
d'Elon musk en disant ah mais Starlink
peut pourrait
apporter le rétablissement des
communications à maotte rapidement
le groupe Orange publ enfin public par
public privé l'sus privé l'état encore
des des part bon bref le groupe
Orange France Télécom bon j'ai 43
ans réagit sur Twitter réagit sur
Twitter pour dénoncer les paroles du
Premier ministre en disant mais nous on
peut ok on est là on est en train de
bosser on va rétablir les communications
pourquoi vous parlez de Starling bon ça
c'est l'anecdote mais pourquoi je parle
de Starling parce que Starling comme
vous
savez dispose des constellations et
Starling il finance ses constellations
avec des programmes de défense aux
États-Unis et espatiau avec la NASA et
Elon Musk c'est lui qui permet la
communication des forces ukrainienne en
Ukraine et d'ailleurs il fait il cache
pas que il peut du jour au lendemain
couper les communications
si il est plus content de de ce que font
les Ukrainiens face au Russ ça a fait
augmenterels de plus de 300 % oui mais
ça c'est la bourse parce que la réalité
industrielle elle est tout autre je vais
en
parler ça c'est la situation Ukraine
mais la situation en Europe c'est
qu'actuellement Starlink est en
négociation avec Meloni en
Italie pour proposer des constellations
peut-être pas maintenant et alors il y a
oui enfin peut-être pas parce que il y a
les les Européens qui commence mais sauf
que ça fait 6 mois qu'ils sont en
négociation les Italiens et pendant 6
mois personne n'en parlait de cet
élément là et donc mélonie elle négocia
dans son coin avec musk tout simplement
pour la constation mais aussi pour plus
grave parce que quand on dit muscle son
son modèle économique c'est qu' il est
spatial intégré c'est il a les lanceurs
mais il a la constellation et il a même
le calcul il a tout il a il a les
communication donc de il a toute la
chaîne c'est là où il est puissant voilà
il a il a toute la chaîne c'est là où il
puissant et stratégique et donc les
Italiens il ils collaboraient avant avec
Arian espace et là ils sont sortis de la
collaboration avec Aren espace sur les
petits lanceurs qui s'appellent je crois
Vega et ces petits lanceurs sont
justement utiles pour lancer des des des
petits satellites de constellation parce
que les constellations de satellite pour
être pédagogique c'est en orbite basse
et donc c'est nué de petits satellites
qui sont en orbite basse mais pour
assurer une continuité du réseau et bon
après il y a des choses techniques que
je ne connais pas mais en gros c'est ça
et les Italiens sont à deux doigts donc
de signer avec musk et c'est
catastrophique pour l'industrie spatiale
européenne ce qu'il en reste pour
l'industrie de défense donc d'ailleurs
Airbus Thalès Alenia qui fait des lance
enfin des lanceurs
et Leonardo groupe italien sont
d'ailleurs en discussion pour s'allier
pour développer une enfin comment dire
renforcer le leurs moyens sur
l'industrie des lanceurs et
elsat a annoncé un partenariat avec
Orange je crois sur l'Afrique là
maiselsat veut revenir dans le jeu d'où
aussi la bourse remonte par rapport à
par rapport à musk à Sting sauf que
c'est plus qu'un contetemps on parlait
de contretemps médiatique là on est en
retard de trois guerres parce que eelsat
ces spécialités c'est pas les petits
satellites qui forment les
constellations c'est les énormes
satellites qui sont très chers c'est pas
du tout la même économie je sais plus un
contact m'avait raconté les rapports les
constellations c'est je je vais pas
sortir de chiff mais c'est des rapports
de 1 à 10 un 100 les les les énormes
satellites de produits jusqu'à présent
parelsat c'est des satellites
géostationnaires qui sont fixes qui sont
très éloignés à 36000 km autour de la
Terre et qui restent en fait qui tourne
à la même vitesse que la rotation de de
la terre et c'est pas ces satellites là
qui sont utilisés justement pour les
constellations donc c'est pas un c'est
pas du tout le même modèle économique
c'est pas il y a aucune chaîne de
production pour l'instant c'est musque
qui les a ou à moindre mesure Jeff
beszos aux États-Unis et donc là il y a
un enjeu sur la on va dire la guerre du
futur la guerre de l'espace la
connectivité entre l'espace la
couverture et la couverture la
coordination des forces armées cruciale
c'est crucial et ces éléments qui sont
cruciaux concernent également un dossier
industriel et financier comme
aos sauf que ça on en parle pas ou très
peu parce que ça par exemple la personne
qui m'a une personne parce qu'il en a
plusieurs qui m'en ont parlé mais sur
l'histoire de la constellation c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît très très très
bien le dossier qui m'a parlé de ça mais
il y a pas une personne qui s'occupe de
d'Atos et qui s'occupe d'intelligence
artificielle que j'ai pu contacter ces
derniers mois qui m'a expliqué le détail
de ce que je viens de raconter alors que
il y a aussi l'actualité en cours donc
ça c'est des choses normalement qui qui
devraient faire en fait débat
politiquement parce que par exemple là
les forces politiques françaises et les
gouvernants même non'ont pas
frontalement polémiquer avec mélonie en
Italie pour dire non mais là tu fais
fausse route en fait
mellonie si on parle de l'Europe si on
parle si tantex ça veut dire quelque
chose mais si on parle en encore si on
veut encore pour reprendre les termes du
président de la République une autonomie
stratégique et une souveraineté
européenne
ou une Europe puissance pour reprendre
toujours les terminologies d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 parce que
effectivement Emmanuel Macron a eu des
des des comment
dire de lucidité non des analyses justes
des analyses justes parce que c'est un
très bon analyste mais c'est un très
mauvais stratège et donc il a les
analyses justes notamment parfois on a
raillé et effectivement le bilan
diplomatique d'Emmanuel Macron est pas
terrible je l'ai écrit j'ai j'ai enquêté
dessus j'ai dit les choses mais il faut
reconnaître que sur certaines analyses
il a posé des mots on reviendra après le
budget de la défense par quoi par 50 ou
100 % 50 % je sais plus exact non mais
il a oui mais oui mais ça c'est des
chiffres c'est des effets d'annonce là
si je fais une petite incise sur les
budget de la défense oui budget de la
défense française là augmente augmente
augmente bon c'est d'ailleurs c'est ce
que réclame à la base Trump hein et on
je reviendrai ça c'est un autre dossier
il compte pas le fait qu'on maintient
notre dissuasion nucléaire à 5ardump
Trump veut surtout que les États
européens augmentent ses budgets de
défense pour acheter des produits
américains voilà c'est ce qu'il a c'est
ce qu'il avait dit déjà lors de son
premier mandat et d'ailleurs Emmanuel
Macron avait été non non je vais revenir
sur disision mais Emmanuel Macron avait
été provoque dans une interview des
économiste en octobre 2019 où il avait
parlé d'état de mort cérébrale de l'OTAN
et là d'ailleurs tout le monde était
tombé sur Emmanuel Macron alors qu'il
disait des choses justes je dois dire
notamment il parlait de fragmentation de
l'Occident en tout cas de risque de
fragmentation de l'Occident et il ce
risque là de fragmentation de l'Occident
il en a reparlé lors de sa
visite il a pas obtenu grand-chose déjà
avec Trump il a pas obtenu grandchose
mais il avait déjà pas obtenu grandchose
en novembre 2022 quand il s'était
déplacé à Washington quand Biden
était
président en quelle année novembre 2022
novembre 2 Emmanuel Macron sauf si je me
trompe dans les dates mais novembre 2022
Emmanuel Macron voyage d'État je crois
en tout cas voyage à Washington en
grande pompe avec les avec Biden avec
les équipes Biden et c'est juste le
moment où les américains annoncent le
grand plan
d'investissement inflation reduction Act
ira
qui annonce plus de 400 enfin près de
400 milliards de dollars
d'investissement dans l'industrie
américaine pour contrer la Chine en fait
et toutes les grandes puissances même
régional Inde Russie et compagnie dans
ce monde des empires qui se constitue
face à nous et là les Européens sont
toalement désemparés et à l'époque
Macron parle du du risque de nouveau de
la fragmentation de l'Occident et
demande que une partie des
investissements américains je crois soit
fléché sur sur l'Europe et c'est ce que
disait Franck bianeri non la dislocation
géopolitique mondiale voilà bon en tout
cas on est dans ce monde
plutôt terrifiant je dois dire
effectivement les gens sont terrifiés
d'ailleurs mais donc Macron il avait
pointer quand même quelques éléments
vous voyez je suis pas untimacroniste
donc je reconnais les les les les
éléments mais encore une fois bonnes
analyses sur certains plans mais pas de
stratégie c'està-dire il a fait beaucoup
d'effit d'annonc donc par exemple sur la
question du budget de la
défense ouais mais juste je finir sur le
budget de la défense ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est quelle est la la
loocation du en terme de budget et et
donc par exemple donc il y a bien
évidemment la dissuasion mais il y a il
y a également euh comment dire il y a
également tous les grands programmes de
défense qui pompent beaucoup d'énergie
notamment le ça a été le cas du Rafal et
donc le problème aussi pour l'armée
française est double parce que bien sûr
il y a dissuasion et là tout le monde en
parle et voilà mais il y a les grands
programmes de défense donc ça veut dire
le peut-être avion européen en terme de
développement le prochain ça a été
annoncé porteavion tout ça ça demande
des un fric dingue et donc il y a aussi
le sujet mais comment on fait avec les
les les forces conventionnelles l'armée
de terre parce que sur une enveloppe
même si elle augmente l'enveloppe euh
quit des des troupes au sol et donc
l'armée française de terre c'est souvent
la dernière dotée dans dans dans cet
élément là alors bien évidemment l'enjeu
c'est la dissuasion c'est aussi
porte-avion mais voilà c'estd que le le
gâteau la vraie question c'est est-ce
qu'on a les moyens la vraie question
c'est est-ce que la est-ce que les
moyens vont être bien employés avec la
stratégie tu parles de porte-avion quand
tu as un porte-avion qui se balade c'est
une cible pour un nuage de drone ça
vient est-ce que la stratégie donc pour
revenir à Macron ouais Macron il est
banquier à la base c'est pas un stratège
c'est pas Emmanuel Macron Sunzu ou
Emmanuel Macron V cl ça j'en ai j'ai
déjà écrit oui effectivement et donc il
est conseillé par qui cet homme
là par plein de gens trop de gens je
dirais et pas assez par G est-ce que ces
gens par exemple en terme de
diplomatie est-ce que ces gens sont
criblés par la DGSE pour savoir si il
traînent pas avec des group chinois ou
des groupes russes ou par
exemple par exemple des groupes
britanniqu ou de l'argent
britannique pour imposer une petite
musique une douce méopé qui puisse
ensuite arriver à nos dirigeants et à
Emmanuel
Macron il y a plein de trucs làdedans on
va revenir après sur la dissuasion mais
sur stratégique le conseil oui enfin
mais même au-delà du Conseil euh plus
globalement la question de l'ingérence
des ingérences la question euh de la de
la porosité de l'État euh à des
influences étrangères bon euh il y a eu
un rapport parlementaire euh euh
Emmanuel Macron parle des ingérences
russes de la déabilissation russse il y
a des trucs il y a bien évidemment des
choses qui existent notamment la
manipulation euh des réseaux sociaux euh
il y a il y a des cyberattaques bon bien
sûr bon tout le monde en fait euh on on
est dans on est déjà dans une guerre
mondiale du renseignement et on est dans
une guerre de la de de la cybersécurité
déjà depuis des années en fait bon donc
euh tous les acteurs s'y mettent en tous
les sens c'est le Far West euh làdedans
il y a quand même quelque chose euh qui
est important
euh c'est que
euh on vous évoquez les services
français on va dire on va dire les mots
qui se baladent ce trava qui
notou notamment on va dire les mots le
donc le
contreespionnage mission en partie la
dgàsi ancien directeur parce y a aussi
la DGSE qui est passé à mais bon en tout
cas les activités de contreespionnage
que ça soit la DGSE DGSI passe le
bonjour d'ailleurs hein passe le bonjour
Voilà
euh amis de promoel Macron monsieur
Lerner bon donc il est très jeune
d'ailleurs bah il a à peu près la même
âge que qu'Emmanuel Macron une quentaine
d'années bon donc le le contreespionnage
sur plusieurs dossiers on peut se poser
des questions sur l'effectivité du
contre-espionnage y compris quand les
cibles et quand la cibleble c'est le
président de la République ou son
entourage ou son entourage donc donc là
je vais faire un peu pourri de choses
qui n'ont pas soit qu' ont été révélé
mais que tout le monde a oublié et tout
le monde les a oublié bon ok pas de
problème he je vais parler de de choses
qui ont été voqué
mais comme ça en passant et qui a
été s'est passé totalement inaperçu mais
pourtant c'est c'est très
grave bon euh sur les trucs ont déjà été
évoqués quand il y a eu l'affaire
benala on s'aperçoit que benala a des
influences particulières et des
entourages particuliers alors
pudiquement on a parlé de France-Afrique
bon en réalité il y avait des intérêts
de renseignement partout là-dedans et
ils étaient pas français voilà quand
mediaap a révélé les fameux contrats
russes mais qui sont Russo azerbaïjanais
et russeau oubékistanais parce que c'est
deux oligarques confié des des contrats
à la société de de benala à l'époque
comme l'a révélé media part à l'époque
aujourd'hui plus personne parle de cette
affaire là alors que Alexandre benala et
l'affaire benala a créé un
une sidération en état de choc du côté
de l'Élysée
bon ça pourrait on pourrait revenir
quand même peut-être sur ça mais il y a
pas eu
d'enquête plus que ça poussé sur ces
éléments là enfin les journalistes
enquêtai j'ai enquêté j'ai dit des
choses d'ailleurs il suffit de lire les
livres et c'est des choses qui
interrogent beaucoup justement quand à
la sécurité nationale et je pèse des
mots les mots plus plus anecdotique plus
récemment passé totalement inaperçu
enfin je dis plus anecdotique que mais
tout aussi grave mais passer inaperçu
parce que l'affaire benala tout le monde
en a parlé
et là deux choses qui sont qui sont
sorties dans la presse l'année dernière
mois de juin 2024 Canard Enchaîné qui
révèle que une bonne partie de la
cellule diplomatique de l'Élysée quand
je dis une bonne partie il y a TR qu
personnes en question qui ne sont plus à
jour d'enquête sur l'habilitation
secretdfense et qui sont toujours en
poste et qui sont et qui ont participé à
des conseils de défense ou qu' ont
participé à des choses secrètes ou qu'
ont eu accès à des documents défense
alors que leur réhabilitation ne sont
plus à jour il avaient quoi comme dans
lesépoches du rouble ou ou de la livre
sterling chinois ah cétait chinois cette
fois-ci enfin entre autres chinois et il
y avait je sais plus quel autre État
peut-être il y avait pas que la Chine
mais il y avait la Chine en tout cas il
y avait pas la Russie mais il y avait la
Chine c'est quand même très
problématique cellule diplomatique de
l'Élysée ça a été révélé dans le canal
enchaîné aucun
commentaire aucun
commentaire je connais un cas
euh sur lequel je travaille d'ailleurs
mais tout aussi
problématique voilà et puis euh autre
élément l'affaire Pegasus
où le téléphone personnel du Président
de la République est potentiellement
espionné par Pegasus logiciel espion
d'uneune société NSO israélienne qui
avait un diplomate français Gérard
Gérard mais mais le ministre la ministre
de la Défense elle a été véroulé son
téléphone éta véroulé oui tout le monde
une bonne partie du
gouvernement beaucoup de gens de
l'Algérie aussi du Maroc plein de gens
autour de laffire
benala hein parce que quasiment tous les
noms qui apparaissent dans le grand
manipulateur dans mon livre du Grand
manipulateurs ont tous été
espionnés sur le dossier Algérie sur la
Libye sur de dossier extrêmement
sensible en diplomatie donc affaire
Pegasus affaire
Pegasus j'ai visionné une de vos
interviews de ces derniers mois Laurent
Richard donc à l'origine de la sortie de
l'affaire qui est le patron de la de la
de forbidan stories qui est comme on
appelle ça consortium de journalistes
qui est établi aux États-Unis qui est
une sorte de collectif de journalistes
qui ont une mission d'ailleurs noble sur
au départ qui est enfin je dis au départ
parce que c'est une mission centrale
c'est de continuer des enquêtes de
journalistes qui ont été assassiné de
par le monde bon c'est eux al là pour le
coup c'est pas une continuation
d'enquête c'est eux avec amnestie
internationale qui dévoile
journalistiquement Pegasus euh il a lu
le le papier de d'une consur Sophie des
désert dans Libération
euh qui est sorti le 28 juillet
2024 la date est importante parce que
c'est la semaine où Emmanuel Macron se
réconcilie diplomatiquement avec Mohamed
VI et avec le Maroc la France et où la
France reconnaît pour la première fois
le Sahara Occidental provoquant lire des
Algériens tout ça on retrouve les
acteurs d'ailleurs euh des
enregistrements Pegasus du Maroc les
Algériens euh les
Israéliens super super mélange bon dans
l'article de Sophie des déserts qui est
très long et très très très important
enfin très intéressant il y a plusieurs
éléments mais complètement dingue mais
on com comme l'a dit un journaliste de
Libération que je connais même même
enfin à Libération on enquête même l'été
bon c'est le tweet qu'il a fait bon et
donc ce ce cette article a pas été
entièrement lu parce que j'en parle
autour de moi et il a pas été lu Laurent
Richard fait référence à ce papier là
mais il oublie des éléments
d'information extrêmement importants
dans ce papier trois éléments
d'information premier élément
d'information il est expliqué que l'un
des proches d'Emmanuel Macron et de
Brigitte Macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2016 2017 que j'ai
cité dans le grand manipulateur je ne
citerai pas le nom ce soir pour des
raisons de diffamation et des raisons de
présomption d'innocence mais c'est
quelqu'un qui était au service
d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne et
qui était chargé d'accompagner
Emmanuel Macron et son épouse sur le
plan personnel et qui était porteur de
valise pas de billet mais porteur de
valise des des des vêtements et et
compagnie cette personneel est présentée
par le journal Libération dans l'article
du 28 juillet 2024 comme un agent
marocain un agent de renseignement
marocain les avocats de la personne que
je ne cite pas ont fait un un communiqué
bizarrement bon ils ont pas eu peur de
l'fest Tron sur les réseaux sociaux
personne n'en a
parlé le communiqué ça disait quoi bah
que c'était des allégations mon souvenir
ENF mensongeaire voilà bon reste que
l'accusation a été porté bon moi je me
suis renseigné les documents
manifestement existent enfin les preuves
existent en tout cas moi je les ai pas
mais euh bon j'ai posé les questions qui
fait que bon mais ça n'a provoqué aucune
réaction bon dans le papier il est
expliqué il est
expliqué je peux parfois parler vite
mais là je parle lentement que le
portable personnel d'Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas été analysé par les services
compétents de l'État après la révélation
de l'affaire les services compétents de
l'État à ma connaissance pour ce
dossier-là c'est la DJS c'est le SGDSN
secrétaire général de la Défense et
Sécurité Nationale il y a aussi un autre
service dont j'ai plus le nom qui
s'occupe plus particulièrement du
respect du secret défense notamment sur
les activités militaires et stratégique
mais là il s'agit de contreespionnage
pur
et ces services n'ont pas analysé le
téléphone selon le journal Libération
mais ils ont pas été contredits qui a
analysé le téléphone
c'est un chargé de mission de l'Élysée
qui s'appelle Alexandre
Carayon qui est au service d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 qui était le monsieur
numérique de la campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron entre 2016 et 2017 c'est un gars
brillant qui a été à l'école 42 que
conna xavieniel et Alexandre Carayon qui
a été nommé chargé de mission très
discrètement à partir de 2017 auprès du
coordinateur national du renseignement
du
CNR instance qui coordonne les services
de renseignement pour l'Élysée c'est à
l'acent de Carayon qui a été chargé par
le Président de la République d'analyser
le téléphone c'est écrit noir sur blanc
dans le papier alors déjà qu'on n' pas
la commission d'enquête qu'on a pas la
transparence sur le dossier et on
apprend dans le papier que les services
qui auraient dû être chargé de faire ça
et qui ont fait ça à plusieurs reprises
dans l'affaire Pegasus auprès des
ministres qui ont été ciblés ou qu'on pu
faire ça je le sais sur un autre dossier
concernant un ministre où il y avait un
son dstabilisation d'un ministre en
l'occurrence euh mince en
l'occurrence François drogi l'ancien
ministre de l'Environnement euh il a
confié son portable à à à des services
enfin au services compétent et
donc je pense que ce qui est écrit
libération est tout à fait vérifié c'est
Sophie deser a fait son blot euh il n'y
a eu aucune
réaction bon c'est
sidérant trème élément d'information
stratégique qu'il y a dans le papiller
de Sophie des désert
euh euh que j'ai
trouvé enfin qui est moins problématique
par rapport à la question de la sécurité
nationale mais qui quand même replace
les choses dans leur contexte il est dit
noir sur blanc que la fuite de documents
en l'occurrence la fameuse liste de
50000 téléphones récupérés par forb
stories c'est écrit noir sur blanc he
par la journaliste
et j'ai les mêmes éléments d'information
en terme de source de renseignement tout
le monde sait que là pour le coup c'est
des intérêts américains alors pas
directement au journalistes les
journalistes je sais pas comment ils ont
récupéré ça mais le monde du
renseignement sa que la fuite et
l'attaque vis-à-vis de Pegasus et donc
de NSO a été faite par la communauté du
renseignement américaine qui voulait
remettre à sa place NSO qui est donc une
boîte privée liée au renseignement
israélien de l'unité spécialisée cyber
offensif unité 8200 bien connu par les
geek et spécial de renseignement
israélienne et donc pourquoi parce que
Pegasus était vendu à la volée on va
dire par netanahou pour sa diplomatie
dans plein d'État européens africain en
disant ah mon pote tu es mon copain je
te file Pegasus tu vas pouvoir espionner
tous tes citoyens tes journalistes tes
opposant et plein d'autres mondes et à
un moment donné la NSE américaine grande
agence de de d'écoute américaine on a eu
un peu ralbol de voir ce bazar là
d'autant plus que les Américains et ça
je l'avais déjà raconté dans l'emprise
dans mon livre mais également ici
euh j'avais raconté la disjonction
stratégique de plus en plus importante
entre Israël et les États-Unis et le
bordel politique entre Biden Trump qui
s'explique aussi par le bordel politique
en Israël avec netanahou euh voilà même
si Trump et netano parfois s'engueulent
et ils se sont engueulés en réalité il y
a une sorte de de de d'alliance euh
stratégique et politique idéologique
entre Trump et netanahou on l'a encore
vu récemment d'ailleurs et ça ça fait
partie des éléments de bascule du monde
et qui explique le constat d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la fragmentation de
l'Occident je vais revenir sur la
dissuasion parce que justement c'est un
lien et il y a un autre sujet j'aurais
aimé aborder mais qui concerne la Sûreté
nationale et sécurité nationale et qui
est un sujet plus gravele en apparence
qui est le narcotrafic mais ça on en
parlera peut-être après si j'ai le temps
encore parce que on parle de de de
logique
mafieuse dissuion hein oui mais on parle
de dissuasion mais on oui on va parler
ça après parce que les logiques
mafieuses peut aussi avoir des soucis de
sécurité nationale parce que c'est des
logiques qui ont comme spécialité la
compromission des élites politiques et
des réensables politiques et bien
évidemment depuis très N nombreuses
années ces logiques mafieuses sont en
fait utilisées comme arme opérationnelle
par les services de renseignement du
monde entier voilà
et la question de la grande criminalité
internationale doit se poser aussi à
l'ône de la question de la sécurité
nationale ça je mets ça de côté mais
après je veux revenir sur ça parce que
c'est important mais pour revenir sur la
dissuasion pour revenir sur la
dissuasion justement cette taxe Trump
netania j'y vais à toute vitesse mais il
faudra lire et je vous ferai un conseil
de lecture auss après mais bon euh un
contact il y a quelques semaines me dit
ah mais les Anglais se sont enfin je
pense qu' ça fait pas enfin mais disons
ils ont enfin réalisé qu'il y avait cet
axe- là
bon pourquoi parce que là aussi il y a
une disjonction de plus en plus
importante entre les intérêts notamment
depuis euh depuis le brexit il y a une
disjonction de plus en plus importante
stratégique entre le Royaume-Uni et les
États-Unis indépendamment d'ailleurs
même de l'arrivée de Trump donc qui a ré
dans les brancards et qui a arrivé comme
un gros bourrin pour tout écraser mais
en fait c'est des là on est dans le
tempslon on est dans le tempson très
concrètement l'objet du désaccord
stratégique entre les Royaume-Uni et et
les États-Unis c'est que le Royaume-Uni
après le brexit ils avent plus de base
industrielle ils l'ont toujours pas
récupéré euh ils sont sortis de l'Union
européenne qui a été une erreur en fait
au final et euh ils sont retrouvés un
peu orphelin ça c'est quelle année ça
bah ça c'est après le brexit donc brexit
entre l'annonce la réalisation
négociation je sais plus mais c'est
entre 2014 et 2016 2017 enfin il y a eu
après il y a eu le package il y a eu une
négociation avec l'Union européenne ça
ça a duré du temps reste que ça
corrobore le fait qu' qu'il se déploie
en Europe sur des espérenseignements et
pas qu'en Europe d'ailleurs aussi au
Moyen-Orient moyen
ils ont
peur ils peur ils sont on va dire ils
sont agressifs d'un point de vue de
renseignement parce que ils ont ils ont
plus grand-chose donc et donc par au
niveau des milieux d'affaires
britanniques au milieu des milieux
d'affaires britanniques et juste petite
incise je vous parlais de Murdock tout à
l'heure c'est important et donc je
disais aussi que Murdock c'était fâché
avec Trump là sur le dossier
ukrainien c'est aussi un et donc le le
en gros les anglais alors il y a les
milieux d'affaires anglais la City la
finance qui est la prunelle de leurs
yeux que c'est ce qui leur reste
quasiment un avantage comparatif et
c'est
important ils sont contre l'endigment
américain vis-à-vis de la Chine ses
milieux
d'affaires parce que ça vaut ça joue pas
leurs intérêts d'autant plus qu'après le
brexit ils ont essayé de jouer de
trianguler avec la Chine et notamment
financièrement avec la place de Hong
Kong mais pas que la Hong Kong il y a il
y a un symbole de ça c'est la banque
HSBC qui est entre Hong Kong système de
financier chinois et l'Angleterre qui
est une banque en fait d'origine
coloniale issue de la guerre de l'opium
dans me souvenir et qui a toujours été
entre l'Asie et l'Europe entre Londres
Hong Kong et les places financières
asiatiques hSBC est devenu de plus en
plus chinois et donc euh ça a posé des
problèmes d'organisation euh et de de de
de de de questionnement d'intégrité du
groupe au niveau financier mais je mets
ça de côté je reviens la City et milieu
d'affaires anglais et ces dernières
années en plus de recevoir les
oligarques russes par ailleurs mais ça
c'est encore un autre sujet euh euh ont
essayé de tirer leur épingle du jeu de
l'histoire coloniale britannique donc de
regarder vers l'Asie ça a été leur ils
ont leur tentative de plonge de salut et
donc bien évidemment la politique de
plus en plus féroce américaine vis-à-vis
de la qui en réalité commencé sous Obama
en fait parce que le le le l'orientation
des
Américains l'abandon des Américains
vis-à-vis de l'Europe en fait ça date
c'est pas uniquement Trump c'est le
temps long d'illeurs même Gerard enfin
je dis même gerérard l'a dit il y a des
arbitrages du temps long qui ont été
fait et que les Européens ont pas voulu
voir et n'ont pas anticipé donc là
maintenant on a l'impression que c'est
des canards sans tête totalement
paniqués par rapport à la situation
géopolitique mais en réalité tous les
signes étaient là depuis 5 10 ans sauf
qu'ils ont pas voulu actualiser leur
cadrage leur lunettes leur paradigme par
rapport au changement des relations
internationales majeures et notamment le
fait que la priorité numéro 1 des
États-Unis c'est l'Asie c'est la Chine
point barre à tout niveau commercial
économique sécuritaire stratégique et
donc le le
le je reviens sur les Anglais les
Anglais ils étaient pas d'accord avec
cette politique d'endigement économique
ou d'ailleurs les Américains sous Biden
mais même Trump ont fait pression sur
les Européens pour que les les les
partenariats économiques même parfois
stratégiques avec la Chine soit
abandonné et la France n'a pas accepté
ça parce que la France a une longue
histoire de relation avec la Chine c'est
un des premiers états car connu
l'indépendance de la Chine en 1949 hein
de GA voilà enfin même avant de Gaulle
même avant de mais effectivement de
Gaulle mais même avant de Gaulle parce
que c'est 49 il y a toute cette histoire
là avec la Chine et et la France a pas
voulu abandonner ça même si sur certains
dossiers ça a posé problème en
Angleterre par exemple sur le dossier
nucléaire civil avec EDF au milieu les
Anglais ont finalement booutter hors des
projets de nouveau réacteur où il y a
EDF les Chinois problème pour les
Chinois problème pour les Anglais et
surtout problème pour EDF les réacteurs
étaient financés par les Chinois
maintenant c'est les Français et EDF qui
financent les réacteurs britannique bon
euh et donc les Anglais ils de plus en
plus ils ont leur propre stratégie pas
uniquement de renseignement mais ils ont
leur propre stratégie par rapport aux
États-Unis on n plus au moment de la
guerre de la deuxème guerre en Irak en
avec Tony Blair et en en 2000 en 2003 on
n'est plus à cette époque làà les
Anglais ne sont plus la pointe à avancé
des
néoconservateurs américains c'est plus
exactement comme ça que ça se passe leur
autonomie alors bah pris le ils essayent
de prendre leur autonomie ils ont pris
leur autonomie à partir de 2016
oui enfin ils essayent enfin enfin en
tout cas quand je dis ils essayent parce
que par exemple on va parler de la
dissuasion voilà mais je vais parler de
la dissuasion la dissuasion britannique
n'est pas une dissuasion britannique
c'est une dissuasion américaine tout le
système Posséidon avec les les
sous-marins nucléaire britannique en
fait une bonne partie de de de de toute
de toute l'infrastructure c'est les
Américains qui livrent ils ont aucune
leur force de disfuasion et quasiment
pas autonome alors justement ça pe avoir
un rapport avec Athos et avec avec Athos
et avec la France
bon on va revenir sur la disision
justement mais mais pourquoi pourquoi je
faisais cette parenthèse importante sur
les Anglais et les États-Unis parce que
justement les
Anglais on l'a pas vu parce que c'était
que les spécialistes défense qui sont
enfin au courant ou spécialist
stratégiqu mais ils se sont tout en euh
avant même le brexit c'est pour ça que
tout ça c'est c'est percuté mais dès
2010 ils se sont rapprochés de la France
au moment où la France est revenue dans
le commandement intégré de l'OTAN bon
décision de Nicolas Sarkozy il y a eu un
accord extrêmement important qui
s'appelle
l'encester en 2010 qui a été signé entre
Sarkozi et je sais plus quel premier
ministre anglais j'ai un trou de mémoire
cet accord là il y a une composante
nucléaire et de dissuasion nucléaire
voilà où en fait il y a une début de
coopération entre les Anglais et les
Français sur la disfuasion nucléaire
donc là quand on parle quand Macron
évoque l'européanisation euh comme effet
d'annonce éventuelle de la force de
dision nucléaire il y a déjà en fait des
collaborations et des coopérations avec
l'autre puissance nucléaire européenne
qui est les Brit qui sont les
Britanniques à peu juste avant ces
accords de Lancaster euh il y avait un
grand programme d'un d'un porte-avion
franco-britannique où la France a
dépensé près de 300 millions d'euros le
porte-avion a été coulé entre guillemets
avant même qu'il existe par les
américains qui voulaient pas de la
coopération et ce por-avion il a coulé
aussi pour des raisons techniques il
faut savoir que sur le porte-avion
Charles de Gaul français aujourd'hui la
catapulte pour envoyer les avions et
fabriqué par les Américains et euh par
ailleurs les Anglais avaient avait
acheté ou était en train acheter du F35
à décollage vertical parce que sur les
les pores-avions britannique en fait
c'est des avions à décollage vertical
c'est leur
tradition donc la France et les Anglais
c'étaient pas ils étaient pas tombés
d'accord avant les accords de Lancaster
depuis les accords de loncaster et suite
à Sarkozi il y a eu petit à petit malgré
ensuite le brexit des renforcements de
coopération alors bien évidemment en
partie dans le cadre de l'OTAN donc les
généraux ils étaient très contents parce
que c'était l'OTAN et et donc voilà et
donc il y avait des normes reste que
fondamentalement ça en fait derrière la
petite musique c'est que les Anglais se
rapprochent de la France et de la
dissuasion nucléaire française il se
rapproche d'une façon conventionnelle ou
il se rapproche d'une façon agressive
est-ce qu'il dis c'est en accord c'est
en accord là non pour le coup là sur là
c'est un vrai accord d'état à état c'est
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai accord
d'état à état c'est ce qui explique
aussi pourquoi les Anglais dans le
nucléaire civil ont donné les contrats à
EDF parce que contrairement à ce qu'on
dit il y a des liens entre le nucléaire
civil et nucléaire
militaire évident notamment en terme de
de combustible c'est le la clé de la non
prolifération d'ailleurs même si oui il
y a des réacteurs qui sont plus plutôt
nigène enfin bon bref ça je vais pas
entrer dans la technique mais voilà ENF
et puis ouais enfin ça c'est encore
autre chose mais effectivement c'est
c'est fait à base de plutonium le MO euh
bref et donc mais
euh c'est aussi pour ça que les Anglais
se sont intéressés au dossier
Athos et que ils ont pas vu d'un bon œil
l'arrivée de kretinski et de
Layani voilà
euhamant de laayani de par ses liens
avec Israël voilà et donc et pour et
pour le coup ils étaient pas en agressif
par rapport à la France ils étaient
soucieux de l'autonomie stratégique
française dans la disuasion nucléaire
pourquoi par rapport à ce que je vous
disais juste avant sur leur
autonomisation enfin leur tentative
d'autonomisation tentative début
d'autonomisation par rapport à
l'écosystème américain voilà ils sont
tellement il ils sont tellement soucieux
maintenant parce qu'ils ont quand même
un nationalisme historique fort les
Anglais hein colonialiste c'est donc ils
sont fiers d' d'être anglais et donc il
ils ont encore ça on va dire et
donc ça s'est pas arrangé après le
brexit jeallis dire et donc et donc il
ils se disent [__] il y a que désolé
il y a que les Français qui peuvent
potentiellement nous aider à à à
récupérer une une une modernisation de
notre dissuasion nucléaire britannique
et donc ça c'est un élément clé ça c'est
pour répondre notamment à à à
l'européanisation potentielle don on a
parlé beaucoup de l'Allemagne mais là il
y a un truc très concret avec les
Britanniques alors bien évidemment après
ça pose plein de problèmes politiques
parce que bien évidemment la stratégie
britannique de sécurité de
euh de positionnement diplomatique y
compris vis-à-vis de Moscou par exemple
n'est pas forcément celle de Paris et
donc ça pose plein de questions ouais
mais leur position est pas la même en
euh vis-à-vis de Moscou que celle de
Paris euh ça les empêche pas de de de
d'arroser de poignons des S tank ou des
S tank en autonomie entre entre 2016 et
2019 pour protéger la pour propager leur
petite mélopé à gauche et à
droite ça c'est leur stratégie
d'influence mais tous les états on une
stratégie d'inluence d' donc pour
revenir à la stratégie d'influence au
service de renseignement il Contin
continuent de faire diléante tong et
crème soleil en laissant le le président
de la République se faire auditer par
ses potes ou ils disent bon quand même
ça devient problématique notre notre
président se fait audité par ses potes
nous on a des spéciaux fait pour ça
sélectionné pour ça avec des gens
criblés de A à Z
oui on revenait sur la question
ouais bah encore une fois là là là il y
a pas forcément de britannique mais par
que Britan qui n intéress beaucoup ok
mais il y a a il y a pas forcément les
Britanniques là-dedans
mais le
le la question de la Sûreté nationale
sécurité nationale par rapport à à
d'éventuelles compromission de
responsable politique en l'occurrence là
le président de la République c'est une
question qui devrait se poser avec plus
d'acuité voilà surtout quand surtout
quand le discours politique fait de la
contreingérence et fait euh de la lutte
contre les ingérences influences
étrangères la priorité numéro 1 bon ils
sont à moitié born c'estàd qu'ils
s'intéressent toujours aux Russes qui se
comportent comme des Russes les Chinois
qui se comportent ils ont raison de
s'intéressé au russes heureusement il
faudrait qu'il s'intéresse aux Marocains
aux Israéliens as suite sauf que mais t
les Britan pass oui mais les les
services de renseignement français
peuvent s'intéresser à tout ça et ils
s'y intéressent après la question c'est
euh c'est l'étage au-dessus du
renseignement et son rapport aux
politique tu vous parlez vous parlez du
de celui qui refuse de faire auditer son
téléphone par les services oui bah donc
ou mais voilà bar quand même revenons à
la dissuion dis voilà parce que je vais
revenir sur la dissuision parce que
c'est c'est
important euh
euh ça c'est important mais je suis
fatigué donc euh non alors
euh
dissuasion donc
mini donc oui je parlait voilis donc pr
première premièrement la la la force de
dissuasion elle a besoin continuellement
d'être modernisée
elle a continuellement besoin d'être
modernisée pour être à jour de la
dissuasion parce que en face les forces
en présence se modernisent et donc
encore une fois l'important de la
disuision c'est l'équilibre stratégique
et donc la question c'est oui c'est de
pas envoyer le missile mais surtout
enfin ça c'est c'est la communément ce
qu'on dit mais en fait pour que personne
n'envoie le missile il faut pas qu'il y
ait déséquilibre stratégique des forces
entre les gens les les États qui sont
dotés aussi alors c'est c'est vrai entre
l'Union euh l'Union soviétique lapsus
entre la Russie et les États-Unis parce
que SC enfin scoop c'est pas un scoop
mais en fait les États-Unis et la Russie
sont actuellement en déséquilibre
stratégique au profit des
Russes et donc ça explique pourquoi
Trump a annoncé ça a été peu
commenté il y a quelques jours sa
volonté d'arriver à un nouveau traité de
des armement nucléaire parce que en
réalité il sait mais Biden aussi savait
que les Américains sont en
retard sur cet équip stratégique sur
deux points bon la question des têtes
nucléaires les les les les les Russes
sont plus de tête nucléaaires 6000 et
quelques je crois enfin selon les
chiffres officiels 5000 et quelques pour
les les Américains ça c'est important
pour pas pas uniquement parce
que ils ont plus de têtees ça je dirais
ça pourquoi pourquoi c'est important
mais après mais le deuxième élément
c'est que les Russes
n'ont en gros les Américains ont
travaillé sur le la défense et sur tout
ce qu'on a appelé les dôes
et les interceptions d'éventuels
missiles intercontinentaux et donc
ilention conventionnel mais
potentiellement aussi nucléaire
potentiellement conventionnel en terme
de vitesse ah oui oui oui oui ils ont
travaillé sur la question des des
lanceurs enfin des des missiles des
vecteurs oui enfin mais en terme en
terme de défense les Russes ont
travaillé en terme de pénétration et
c'est ce qu'on appelle les missiles
hypersoniques qui sont à la fois plus
véloces qui passent dans un stratosphère
ça comme tous les missiles inter
intercontinentaux mais en plus qui sont
tirés de sous-marins dont le but du jeu
c'est de disparaître de ne pas savoir où
sont les sous-marins pourquoi c'est
important c'est parce que quand le
missile il sort du sous-marin c'est ce
qui permet de calculer ensuite sa
trajectoire et donc ça déjà de pas
savoir où le missile sera tiré c'est un
problème en terme de sécurité de défense
et de le Miss hypersonic en plus il est
aléatoire en terme de trajectoire donc
il il gruge potentiellement les les
systèmes les intercepteurs et systèmes
de défense les fameuses les fameux
domôes héritent en partie de du rêve de
Rean de de la guerre des éto la fameuse
guerre des étoiles et compagnie et donc
autant sous Rean les Américains avaient
gagné le le Game aussi d'un point de vue
stratégique et après on reviendra juste
peut-être sur le pétrole
donc dans les Ann 80 autant aujourd'hui
en fait c'est les Russes qui sont
malheureusement j'allais dire mais qui
sont en position de force vis-à-vis des
Américains ça explique beaucoup de
choses sur l'attitude américaine y
compris vis-à-vis du dossier ukrainien
et encore une fois Trump ou même avant
Trump parce que là aussi il y a des
différences entre sur le dossier
ukrainien entre les Britanniques et les
Américains quoi que disent les trolls
russes quoi que disent les
propagandistes de l'autre côté les
propagandistes des deux bords euh les
Européens
euh c'est Pierre vimmont qui était haut
diplomate qui a été je crois directeur
de cabinet Dominique VMA à un moment
donné il y a très longtemps mais qui qui
a été nommé par le Président de la
République vous parliez des conseillers
du président de la République pierre
vimon a été après Chevénement a été
nommé envoyé spécial de la France
vis-à-vis de la Russie et de Moscou
avant 2022 entre 2020 et 2022 en 2020 en
février 2020 il donne une une une
allocution devant des sénateurs ou des
députés et il explique que il ne
faudrait pas que les Européens euh que
le dialogue stratégique euh que dans le
dialogue stratégique donc nucléaire
entre puissance nucléaire se fasse au
détriment des Européens et que ça passe
au-dessus des Européens entre Moscou et
Washington on est en 2020 bon c'est déjà
Trump là mais c'est Pierre Vimont
qu'alerte euh euh le le le même mois en
février 2020 2020 c'est déjà février
2020 euh bah c'est non c'est encore
Trump février 2020 oui c'est c'est fin
2020 l'élection février 2020 c'est
également Macron donne un discours très
très très important à l'école de guerre
où il parle déjà
d'européanisation enfin en tout cas de
de de développement de partenariat
européens et il pense à l'Allemagne
parce que le débat en Allemagne s'est
développé à partir de 2017-2018 dans
certains Cerces de réflexion à Berlin
c'est important parce que on le rappelle
jamais assez l'OTAN c'est avant tout une
alliance nucléaire on le dit pas assez
l'OTAN c'est une alliance nucléaire le
parapluie nucléaire américain c'est
l'OTAN et c'est très important à à
comprendre parce que les Allemands
toutes leur force de défense et
notamment c'est pour ça qu'ils achètent
du F35 c'est lié oui à
l'interoparabilité comme on dit de
l'OTAN mais c'est lié parce que c'est
lié également au fait qu'ils ont des
bombes nucléaires américaines sur le
territoire bon en fait c'est c'est
globalement symbolique hein quand même
par qu'ils peuvent pas en faire
grand-chose sans l'accord des États-Unis
mais c'est comme il y a des bombes
nucléaires aussi américaines en Turquie
en Belgique et je crois qu' j'ai oublié
un État européen dans le
Lot et c'est ce qui constitue le
parapluie nucléaire américain enfin
européen
américain bon et donc Macron à l'école
de guerre il dit bon il faudrait
peut-être déjà il dit ça déjà il dit ça
mais ça pose Pasin de problème
d'ailleurs moi pour l'emprise j'avais
interrogé François Hollande sur cette
hypothèse là et il avait dit non mais ça
c'est pas possible parce que de toute
manière il y aura jamais il m'a fait la
réponse que j'ai cité il y aura jamais
de codécision avec les Allemands sur le
dossier nucléaire
euh alors là on parle de codécision en
amont hein on parle pas du bouton
nucléaire de toute façon ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le bouton nucléaire
c'est le président français point barre
et c'est pour ça qu'on a aussi la 5e
République aussi verticale et et
compagnie euh c'est parce que le le même
si euh tout tout enfin le général de
Gaulle en tout cas a pensé à la 5e
République y compris par rapport à la
responsabilité du Président de la
République par rapport à dans son rôle
dans la disuasion nucléire ça il faut
faire il faut rappeler ça mais donc
euh je reviens sur les forces en
présence et le déséquilibre euh
stratégique euh parce que on voit bien
que là dans les discussions sur
l'européanisation audelà enfin éventuel
d'un parapluie français on voit bien que
là c'est pas trois 00 ogives françaises
qui peut stratégiquement contrebalancer
6000 ogives euh russes 300 ogives
françaises qui sont potentiellement
intercepable
courtcircuableou non mais et donc ah oui
et donc quand je parlais du nombre
d'ogif pourquoi c'est important parce
que effectivement on pourrait se dire
mais pourquoi ils ont autantogive il
faut savoir que pendant la guerre froide
euh justement à la course à l'armement
nucléaire c'était monté à plus de 10000
ogives des deux côtés hein euh
euh terrifiant mais pourquoi il y a ce
nombre deogif parce que forcément la
dissuasion elle elle elle elle elle
fonctionne également sur bah justement
la la la capacité à faire peur au sens
sur la l'efficacité
l'effectivité de la réalisation de
l'attaque et notamment de la de la du
déplacement à des milliers dizaines de
milliers de kilomètres parfois de la de
de la charge nucléaire contre la cible
et donc plus on a de de missiles
notamment aussi des des des des missiles
avec multiples têtes et plus bah c'est
je sais pas c'est comment si on on
envoie plein de plein de munition d'un
coup sur une cible bah c'est plus
difficile de les arrêter donc la
question du nombre deogiv doit rentrer
dans le dialogue stratégique depuis le
début des années 2000 tous les grands
accords entre la Russie et les
États-Unis les uns après les autres sur
la question de l'équilibre stratégique
en terme de de d'engagement désarmement
nucléaire les uns après les autres euh
sont tombés euh par la faute des
Américains par la faute des Russes ils
ont pas été renouvelés il y a pas eu une
négociation là je crois que le dernier
traité c'est new start et il doit
arriver à la fin en
2026 donc il y a plus beaucoup de mois
pour renégocier tout tout ce bordel là
et c'est un dossier très compliqué donc
je m'excuse parce que je je fais des des
des
euh des
digressions j'espère pas d'imprécision
et j'espère de j'espère pas de
d'incompréhension enfin j'espère d'être
assez
pédagogique derrière cette on de
l'équilibre stratégique se pose la
question de la prolifération
nucléaire parce que donc depuis 1968 il
y a le traité de non prolifération
nucléaire TNP qui a été signé
euh bah par toute une partie des pays la
France ne l'a ratifié qu'en 1992 il faut
le savoir euh et euh en fait qui
considère qu'il y a cinq puissances
nucléaires officielles et que après les
autres États et que ces cinq puissances
nucléaires officielles s'engagent à ne
pas participer à la
prolifération bon prolifération en terme
de tête ou prolifération en terme de
partage de la force de alors mais c'est
de technologie mais la mais partage la
force ça veut rien dire mais justement
ça pose une question de
prolifération quand j'entends sur un
plateau télé hier soir sur LCI que euh
euh que il faut euh
euh euh c'est c'est la grand reporter de
L'Express dont j'ai oublié le nom mais
euh dit il faut armer les Polonais de
l'arme atomique euh on s'en fout je
crois qu'elle a même dit quasiment peu
importe la prolifération les bras m
tombe euh les Nations-Unies depuis plus
de 20 ans alertent sur euh la
prolifération nucléaire les risques de
prolifération
nucléaire c'est au nom de ce risque de
prolifération nucléaire que les
Ukrainiens ont accepté en 1994 de signer
le mémorandum de Budapest et accepté de
ramener les têtes et tout le matériel
nucléaire du côté de Moscou euh avec un
engagement de garantie euh de sécurité
notamment nucléaire qui en fait n'a pas
été respecté par les Russes mais pas non
plus par lesautres forces occidentales
parce que parce qu'en fait les les les
les
Américains là pour le coup quand
peut-être il fallait réagir àends ils
ont pas réagi en tout cas pas
suffisamment je pense à Obama
notamment bon mais donc même en random
de Budapest c'est les Ukrainiens qui
abandonnent les les forces nucléaires
alors il y a les les les partisans des
Russes qui disent ah mais vous pourquoi
vous dites ça parce que j'ai entendu ça
parce que ils avaient pas le bouton
c'est Moscou qui avait le bouton oui
enfin sauf qu'il faut expliquer l'Union
soviétique krutchev était ukrainien
l'Union soviétique et l'Ukraine c'était
quasiment un même état une partie de
l'industrie nucléaire militaire de
l'Union soviétique était en Ukraine les
Ukrainiens ils ont les capacités en
terme d'ingénierie de cerveau de
documents de même de réserve de
plutonium Tchernobyl euh ils ont euh ils
ont et ils ont surtout les vecteurs
c'estàdire ils ont la technologie de
missile et et et à même d'une manière il
y a quelques années bien plus puissante
que les Russes enfin maintenant les
Russes ont rattrapé leur retard mais les
Ukrainiens ont tout ça d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que zinski a fait des des des
programmes de missile là il y a eu des
annonces en très rapidement pas missile
nucléaire mais missile tout tout court
parce que ils ont les
ingénieurs bon
et donc mémorandum de
Budapest une des pierres angulaires du
mémorandum de budavest c'est la nonpr
ération parce que à l'époque les
Américains ont extrêmement peur de de de
que en Ukraine qui est aux mains des
oligarques et des mafias que le stock
d'armes nucléaires présent en Ukraine
soit
récupéré et simé par des marchands
d'armes par des mafias par des intérêts
par des terroristes par des des
terroristes liés à des états on on on on
est dans ce contexte là il faut le
rappeler quand même dans les années 90
et il y a même un grand film
hollywoodien et un tiré d'un d'un polar
de Tom clany qui s'appelle je sais plus
la référence mais qui a donné un film
honien qui parle de ça avec un une
ogive venant de l'Ukraine qui se
retrouve sur le territoire américain
enfin bon c'est c'est le c'est un
scénario de de film l'occurrence mais et
de et de polar mais le risque était le
risque était là le risque somme de
toutes les peurs non qu'est-ce qu' y a
la somme deou la somme de toutes les
peurs tout à fait la somme de toutes les
peurs et à l'époque il y a juste un un
au début des 90 un grand spécialiste de
stratégie américaine mais Don j'ai euh
j'ai peur d'écorcher le nom et je sais
plus comment il s'appelle
euh bon bref il y a je retrouverai qui
euh qui avait d'ailleurs alerté parce
que lui euh avait dit euh vu les les les
tensions historiques entre l'Ukraine et
la Russie là qui remonte à 2 TR siècles
parle de celui qui est mort plus de 100
ans c'est peut-être lui John quelque
chose j'ai oubl non bon enfin je suis
fatigué et lui avait dit
que il faud il faudrait que l'Ukraine
reste dotée nucléairement voilà bon
alors pourquoi je raconte ça parce que
juste avant la guerre de 2022 chez les
Ukrainiens il y a eu la montée de cette
problématique là de cette thématique là
d'ailleurs à la conférence de sécurité
de Munich de 2022 3 jours avant
l'attaque russe il y a Zelinski qui fait
un discours et il dit nous n'avons pas
cette arme nous n'avons pas la sécurité
en parlant en refaisant référence au
mémorandum de Budapest et donc bien
évidemment la crise
ukrainienne est un un exemple parfait du
risque de prolifération parce qu'en fait
un état qui a abandonné ses forces
nucléaires enfin même si on va dire
elles étaient en codécision oui ils
avaient pas le bouton nucléaire mais
enfin ils avaient en gros pour pour pour
pour être plus pédagogique c'était une
de fait que les armes soient euh refiler
à Moscou ou qu'il en reste ou de toute
manière les moyens techniques les les
les technologiques les ressources de
plutonium les les réacteurs tout était
sur place et c'est ce qu'on appelle une
puissance du seuil comme l'Iran et donc
l'Ukraine est dans cette situation là
même encore aujourd'hui puissance du
seuil d'ailleurs zeninski a plusieurs
fois quand les Américains lui ont refusé
l'entrer dans l'ut temp parce que ça
était le cas et Biden comme Trump
d'ailleurs il faut arrêter de raconter
des histoires ire parce que la CIA c'est
quelque chose c'est autre chose c'est
services de renseignement ils ont fait
leur leur Popot de leur côté avant avant
2020 avant 2014 mais tuentend par Popot
bah ils ont eu une activité de
renseignement offensive en Ukraine bon
tout le monde le sait maintenant c'est
même c'est même raconté dans le New York
Times donc tout le monde le sait mais
c'est pas parce que le les services
enfin certains services d'enseignement
américain ont une stratégie qui était
d'une certaine époque qu'ensuite ça a
été suivi de décisions politiqu
ou d'une que cette stratégie a perduré
ça c'est faux et donc le le le le
discours de certains partisans russes
est faux factuellement faux c'est faux
donc dans ce dans cette situation là
quand les Américains à plusieurs
reprises ont refusé à l'entrée de des
Ukrainiens dans le cadre de
l'OTAN encore une fois alliance
nucléaire zinski à plusieurs reprises a
a mené une petite musique pour menacer
les Américains en gros pour rappeler les
engagements du mémorandum de Budapest
bon ça il était dans son droit tout à
fait mais il a été plus loin parce que
il a il a plusieurs reprise même s'il a
fait ça d'une manière diplomatique il a
rappelé que l'Ukraine était une
puissance du seuil voilà bon euh parce
que là on parle de choses sérieuses quoi
il faut arrêter de de de il faut arrêter
de de de raconter des conneries euh je
suis désolé d'être trivial mais c'est
dangereux là ça ça ça commence à bon et
donc la crise
ukrainienne fait que
les États non dotés
ou en en situation de seuil peuvent se
dire
aujourd'hui bah si j'ai pas d'arme
atomique je peux être envahi et on est
dans cette situation là aujourd'hui ce
qui fait que et il y a pas que ce
dossier là même si la Libye était pas du
tout en puissance de seuil enfin même ça
a été dit en tout cas la comment dire la
la la remise euh comment dire après la
mise au banc de de Kaddafi au début des
années 2000 donc la reprise du dialogue
diplomatique entre les Occidentaux et
Kaddafi l'un des engagements de Kaddafi
c'est pas uniquement la la
reconnaissance du terrorisme libien
c'est également la la la la l'abandon
officiel de la Libye d'un programme
nucléaire bon euh bien évidemment il y a
plein de chefs d'État étrangers qui ont
vu que enfin notamment autoritaire hein
euh il faut pas se leurer qu' ont vu que
la Libye abandonne je sais pas s'ils
étaient en capacité je crois pas mais
donc mais ils ont politiquement
abandonné le prramme clairire et il y a
eu une guerre très très agressive des
des Occidentaux menés par la France
Nicolas Sarkozi les Britanniques et en
soutient les Américains bon donc tout ça
tout tout le monde toutes les puissances
moyennes petites grandes l'ont vu
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que les les
nord coréen alors qu'ils ont une
économie exangue et un système social
exang se sont jetés euh corzeam et pour
la population et dans un état
totalitaire pour le programme
nucléaire pareil l'Iran parce que là
aussi c'est pareil il y a une sorte de
Domino si les Israéliens sur le dossier
ukrainien avaient également une musique
différente
vis-à-vis de de de de certains discours
très en soutien des Ukrainiens ce qui
est normal aussi enfin en tout cas en
tout cas c'est des soutiens qui
s'entendent et qui sont compréhensibles
aussi par rapport à l'invasion et bien
les les Israéliens c'est que ils ont
aussi un con une question de
prolifération vis-à-vis de l' mais
pourquoi parce que Israël est une
puissance nucléaire non
officielle euh je le rappelle mais c'est
quand même bon c'est plus un scoop mais
il faut quand même le rappeler et donc
depuis les années 70 80 les les
puissances arabes proches d'Israël ont
toujours essayé de de d'engager des
programmes nucléaires ça a même été le
cas de l'Irak quand l'Irak était quand
l'Irak
était soutenu par la la France et la
France a livré un un un réacteur
nucléaire aux iraakiens et ça s'est
terminé très mal parce que les
Israéliens ont
euh ont sont intervenus militairement
contre le réacteur eu et ils ont
bombardé aux Irak donc était le réacteur
livré par les Français en Irak bon ça
toute cette histoire là euh bon j'ai pas
porté le bouquin mais toute cette
histoire là passionnante sur Irak Iran
et Israël sur les années 50 60 70 et
l'histoire de la France et la
responsabilité de la France là-dedans
euh responsabilité de la France je vais
préciser c'est raconté par Pierre Péan
dans un livre formidable qui s'appelle
les deux bombes voilà les deux bombes la
bombe irakienne la bombe la bombe
israélienne euh et ça a été réédité
après la première guerre du Golf parce
que Péan assure que euh une des raisons
de la première guerre du golf en réalité
c'était aussi lié à cette questionlà de
de la l'éventualité que Sadam Hussein
euh ensuite le fameux discours de la
deuxème guerre du golf qui était
fallacieux sur les armes de destruction
massive mais le le le l'origine ça vient
de là en fait et pourquoi je dis
responsabilité de la France parce que la
France et pas de De Gaulle mais au
départ la SFIO la 4e République euh les
ingénieurs du CEA à l'époque
euh ont en partie permis à Israël de de
d'avoir les moyens d'avoir la bombe euh
de Gaul a interrompu cette collaboration
euh totalement après euh la gerre de 6
jour de 67
euh bon il y a toute cette histoire qui
est méconnue mais qui est importante
pétle dissuasion Ukraine ouais alors je
juste enfin prolifération euh les
différents secrétaires généraux des
Nations Unies alerte et multiplie les
les les alertes depuis 10 ans euh tout
le monde s'en fout tout le monde s'en
fout euh en France il y a un un ancien
ministre de la Défense qui est décédé
euh Paul killess socialiste qui sur les
10 dernières années de la fin de sa vie
a n'a pas je crois qu'il était sénateur
n'a pas arrêté de mettre en avant la
question de la la prolifération et du
désarmement hein parce que les deux les
deux sont liés les deux sont liés euh et
donc là par exemple dans les
informations que j'ai euh dans la
reconfiguration des cartes avec Trump et
je parlais de Trump netaniahù euh Trump
contrairement à la administration Biden
euh qui a tout fait euh alors on se
souvient lors du premier Trump du
premier mandat Trump dans le premier
mandat Trump euh Trump les accords avec
je sais plus comment il s'appelait euh
les accord sur nucléaire iranien il les
a
bzardé sur demande de netanahou et Biden
a toujours essayé enfin Biden en suite
donc administration Obama a toujours
essayé de retrouver un dialogue avec les
Iraniens parce ils étaient pas sur la
même stratégie donc je parlais quand je
parlais de différenciation stratégique
entre Israël et les États-Unis on est en
plein dedans aussi sur la question
iranienne et le Trump a nommé Poutine
négociateur auprès des Iraniens ah ben
ça j'ai pas vu ça mais donc oui et
pourquoi il y a un enjeu là parce que
Israël de netanahu n'a pas caché sa
volonté potentiellement d'attaquer
l'Iran sur le programme nucléaire euh là
enfin c'est ce qui se passe en coulisse
là actuellement donc quand euh ça c'est
un élément très important la la comment
dire les tensions sur la prolifération
la question nucléaire parce que quand je
terminais mon mon livre l'EM prise en
2022 enfin que je publie en janvier 2022
juste avant la guerre en
Ukraine je termine le
livre ça s'appelle à la p à la
périphérie du monde c'est la c'est la
conclusion et je dis il faut s'attendre
à ce que l'Europe se retrouve face à la
guerre dans ses ou dans ses marches dans
son r tour et pourquoi je dis ça parce
que à la fois je j'ai dans le livre
j'explique que les Américains sont
tournés vers l'Asie et la Chine en
priorité mais et donc que ça pose en
fait une question également de du
parapluie nucléaire et c'est pour ça que
je dis dans le livre contrairement à la
petite musique anachronique qu'on peut
trouver partout on n'est pas dans un
retour de la guerre froide
traditionnelle tout simplement parce que
la guerre froide d'aujourd'hui c'est
entre les États-Unis et la Chine et pas
entre les États-Unis et les Russes
malheureusement ou heureusement ce qui
fait que ça quoi comme conséquence c'est
que les engagements américains sur le
paraplu nucléaire en Europe ça fait
longtemps que les Américains vont plus
n'engagent plus en
réalité totalement leurs paroles et
leurs leur engagement je me répète
vis-à-vis de ce parapluie nucléaire
américain sur l'Europe d'où mon constat
de bon qui
était comment dire constat qui était
réaliste voilà réaliste enfin qui j'ai
qui annonçait pas la guerre en Ukraine
mais qui était réaliste sur le fait que
pourquoi je parlais de la périphérie du
monde déjà je disais aux Européens les
Européens sont devenu la périphérie du
monde sauf que comme on adore se
regarder de nombril on a l'impression
que tout tourne tout tourne autour de
nous mais en plus je disais à la
périphérie du monde par rapport à la
référence de la guerre froide historique
où on parlait des des conflits
périphériques c'était là les conflits
périphériques c'était là où les deux
grandes puissances qui se faisaient la
guerre froide l'URSS et les États-Unis
se euh comment dire continuait la guerre
ou plutôt avait des guerres
conventionnelles par proxy euh donc en
Afrique en Asie B ça été la guerre du
Vietnam en le terrain en Amérique du Sud
aussi dans le renseignement pinochek
arrive donc tout cet univers là il était
dans la de la périphérie du monde de
l'époque et les Européens étaient au
cœur mais de la tension nucléaire ils
étaient d'une certaine manière protégés
par l'équilibre stratégique c'était
dangereux hein mais ils étaient protégés
et là comme le jeu se reforme totalement
euh en fait il y a un risque de guerre
sur tout le pourtour de l'Europe et sur
les marches de l'Europe et et donc sur
le terrain européen parce que ça a été
l'Ukraine c'est c'est pour ça qu'il y a
eu ce ce ce com dire la nature àur du
vide désolé de faire une une remarque un
peu la palissade mais c'est ça explique
pourquoi il y a eu cette dégradation si
soudaine de la question de la sécurité
européenne et autour en fait et et et et
et donc voilà
euh euh je sais pas quelle heure il est
donc ça fait 3h34 qu'on est en interview
on va arriver à la fin de notre
interview je vais te poser je vais vous
poser une dernière question
euh vous le sentez comment le réarmement
européen les milliards de milliers de
milliards que tout le monde promet
Ursula qui promet des milliards la
Chancellerie monde qui promet des
milliards les Norvégiens les Suédois il
y a plusieurs choses opé pour l'instant
un je je vais essayer de faire plus
court parce que là il est très très tard
opération opérationnellement
euh c'est pas trop tard c'est c'est
jamais trop tard mais je veux dire
opérationnellement comme je le dis c'est
quelque chose qui aurait dû être préparé
il y a 20 ans donc
euh donc qu'on fait les Russes ce qu'on
fait les Russes ce qu'on fait les Russes
parce que par exemple les Russes dans le
nucléaire civil par exemple mais qui est
lié au complexe militaire industriel
russe rose atome donc le conglomérat du
du nucléaire civil qui qui je le
rappelle encore aujourd'hui vend la
majorité des des réacteurs nucléaires
dans le monde
euh et je rappelle d'ailleurs à cette
occasion là que le nucléaire russe est
exemple de des sanctions occidentales ce
qui est bon la livraison de combustible
aussi et de livraison de combustible euh
tout à fait euh
euh qu'est-ce que je voulais ajoué euh
[Musique]
oui donc je disais rosat mais là je
faisais une parenthèse je vais arrêter
donc en tout cas Poutine est très
agressif sur le nucléaire civil depuis
20 ans il a il a monté une machine de
guerre pour vendre des réacteurs
nucléaires
partout c'est un problème surtout quand
il vend des réacteurs
nucléaires au Maroc
euh en Turquie euh
voilà c'est quand même dans le retour
européen donc bon bon mais ça fait pas
les gros titres ça bon comme d'ailleurs
au passage le fait que les les
importations de gaz GNL de gaz naturel
liqufié par bateau euh donc à la fois
américains mais russes ont ont augmenté
pour la France à cause de la rupture de
livraison par les par les gazoducs et il
faut savoir donc que la France importe
beaucoup de GNL russe du fait de Total
énergie de sa stratégie avec le champ
gazier ayamal qui est à Mourmansk dans
le Nord et total même si ils ont plus la
maîtrise de leurs actions à toujours 20
% du rus novateek ils ont un pe peu
diminué mais dans dans dans dans dans ce
projet là et donc c'est toujours total
énergie qui importe enfin qui est
l'opérateur pour importer le gaz naturel
liqufié russe et ça c'est pareil ça fait
combien de temps on est en 2025 ça fait
donc 3 ans que le conflit a démarré
enfin le conflit d'invasion pure a
démarré
euh ça continue enfin il y a quelques
articles de presse mais ça ça ça
continue bon donc bon quelle est la
cohérence là-dedans voilà si on a une
stratégie on l'amène jusqu'au bout voilà
mais on fait pas des effets d'annonce
d'un côté
euh pour faire des éditoriax et de
l'autre côé aussi et de l'autre côté il
y a pas de stratégie donc euh sur sur ça
je pense donc sur le plan opérationnel
ça va être super compliqué parce que de
toute façon par exemple
là une bonne partie des États européens
achètent pas d'armes françaises faut le
savoir ou très peu la plupart des armes
français c'est pour ça qu'elles sont
exportées dans des pays à risque de par
le monde on est le deuxième exportateur
mondial maintenant après les Américains
mais parce que les Européens n'achètent
pas d'armes françaises notamment les
avions parce que les F35 soi-disant sont
char g de récupérer la bombe nucléaire
américaine donc c'était ça le le le
schéma donc là il faut ENF il faut tout
remettre à PL sauf que quand il y a
mélony qui négocie avec musk Starling ce
que j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure calmer
un peu là ouais oui mais enfin bon il y
a Trump en face hein donc Trump il a
certains arguments et et donc juste un
élément il y a un élément là aussi
d'ffet d'annonce et de la situation est
terrifiante par certains aspects mais
mais il y a un y a un effet d'effet
d'annonce et il y a aussi un effet de
dramatisation des responsables
politiques parce que à défaut de
stratégie et d'anticipation il comble il
comble oui il court et donc le problème
là il y a quand même un un souci c'est
que en fait les 800 milliards d'euros
que Van derlan a évoqué c'est le rapport
dragy d' y a 6
mois qui concernait pas que la défense
qui sont concern également les une
nouvell technologie enfin biotechnologie
les intelligence artificielle tout ce
qu'on veut enfin bon bref parce que
l'Europe était totalement en retard
parce que j'évoquais l'IRA américain en
en 2000 en 2022
euh c'est aussi pour ces raisonsl que
les les Européens parlent des 800
milliards d'euros c'est en gros je
m'exprime mal c'est euh c'est comme un
peu au moment du covid comme le moment
du covid les responsabl européens
attendent euh quand minuit est passée
euh
de prendre les décisions difficiles et
en l'occurrence là la remise en cause
des règles budgétaires européennes euh
et que l'Allemagne imposait à tout le
monde depuis plus de 30 ans ce qui fait
qu'il y a pas eu de développement
industriel européen et de de la
recherche européenne parce que
contrairement aux États-Unis
contrairement à la Chine la puissance
publique a été empêchée les États
européens ont été empêchés d'investir de
l'argent dans tous ces programmesl alors
alors qu'il faut arrêter de se raconter
des histoires c'est pas le marché qui
fait les qui fait les innovations
contrairement à ce qu'on dit ce que les
néolibéraux disent non c'est la
puissance publique qui fait les
principales innovations Internet le web
tout ça ça vient des investissements de
l'armée américaine ça vient de la NASA
ça vient des investissements publics des
années 50 des anné 60 euh quand vous
regardez la télé en ce moment euh est-ce
que ça ressemble au bourrage de crâne de
1930 je la regarde plus donc je je sa je
sais pas mais euh je enfin non on peut
pas faire de comparaison historique
euh le le le le
le la maîtrise des journalistes et des
experts de plateau télé sur ces sujets
clés ses
anticipations non mais l'exemple sur la
l'exemple l'exemple mais l'exemple sur
la prolifération non c'est pas possible
on peut pas dire la prolifération on
s'en fout on va donner des bombes enfin
des bombes nucléaires l'exemple
l'exemple de les Russes piquent des
machines à laver pour faire des missiles
ça je je je je sais plus cet exemple là
mais mais
peut-être mais voilà enfin enfin les les
missiles hypersonicques c'est pas des
machines à laver quoi voilà bah bon on
av pas remarqué ah Marquand novel est-ce
que vous avez trois livres à conseiller
à notre j'en ai plus alors c'est pas non
euh sur la sur la presse j'ai j'ai sur
la presse j'ai deux livres à conseiller
mais qui sont un peu pas ardus mais
enfin j'ai j'ai un
livre alors résultat on n pas parlé de
mafia mais bon c'est pas grave si si si
si mafia mafia
Nafia narcotrafic et pression sur les
politiques ouais quand on a de la poute
dans le nez est-ce qu'on est plus
facilement c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
ça que je disais mais on en parlera une
autre fois parce que là je suis fatigué
euh non mais sinon sur total il y avait
tout un truc mais non mais ça ça ça fera
partie de d' je vais écrire des articles
euh donc ça euh c'est un historien de la
presse et de l'édition qui s'appelle
Jean y Moler
euh édition pin qui a fait un formidable
ouvrage donc ça s'appelle l'âge d'or de
la corruption parlementaire 1930- 1980
euh c'est un ouvrage historique mais
très précis donc certains trouveront
ardu mais c'est très bien écrit et très
très didactiquement écrit et ça en fait
ça raconte l'histoire du groupe lagarder
euh et comment le groupe lagardire dans
les années 40 a totalement collaboré
avec l'occupant naasie et comment le
groupe lagardè sortie de la guerre
contrairement aux engagements du Conseil
National de la Résistance a réussi à ne
pas se faire nationaliser notamment en
ce qui concerne la distribution de la
presse et qui est en qui était en partie
ensuite contrôlé par la garder via les
nouvelles messagerie de la presse
parisienne et ça raconte comment ce
lobbing euh du groupe lagardire qui
était pourtant un
groupe comment
dire collaborationniste euh a fait du
mais aussi en par la corruption
politique de la 4e République voilà ça
c'est jean-y Moler l'âge d' corruption
parlementaire ça c'est les patrons de
par national tous mauvais donc le titre
est assez cache c'est un ouvrage de Jean
Stern que je connais je précise et ça
date de septembre 2012 mais il y a déjà
tout et notamment il explique don c'est
un ancien journaliste de La Tribune et
Libération et qui explique on parlait
tout à l'heure la presse ça perd de
l'argent bon j'aurais pu avoir cette
réponse je l'ai pas eu mais là je
réponds d'une certaine manière oui ça
perd de l'argent mais c'est presque fait
prè exprès pour les oligarques et les
propriétaires de médiia parce que non en
comptablement ils ont intérêt à ce que
la presse perde de l'argent parce que ça
leur permet via des structures de
holding de remonter le bilan comptable
de ces pertes là et de de défiscaliser
tout ça à travers les dispositifs de
holding comme le dit Xavi Niel la France
est un paradis fiscal c'est vrai et
puis et puis les trois conseils de
lecture je vais commencer par un
scandale sanitaire
c'est je sais pas comment on le prononce
Patrick raden ki qui est un journaliste
d'investigation américain qui a fait un
énorme
travail l'empire de la douleur c'est sur
la crise des opioïdes aux États-Unis
c'est un bouquin qui a peu été relayé en
France c'est dommage c'est du
journalisme américain c'est super bien
écrit il a travaillé pendant 2 ans ou 3
ans je sais plus et c'est sur l'histoire
de la famille Sacla qui est qui était
propriétaire donc de la la boîte de de
de Pharm pharmaceutique qui est à
l'origine de la plus grave crise des des
des opioïdes euh des aux États-Unis
euh ça c'est très intéressant pour
comprendre les les enjeux de lobbying et
de de de de Big
euh Pharma aux États-Unis pirere la
douleur
euh ça je l'ai pas fini donc je bon
c'est un conseil mais que que que j'ai
pas fini de lire j'ai pas fini de l euh
c'est au seuil la tech quand la silicone
valet refait le monde c'est un
sociologue qui a passé je crois 5 ans en
Californie c'est très sociologique qu
présentation mais ça c'est intéressant
parce que ça parle également des modes
de vie de collaboratif il a il a
rencontré les les les gens de la tech et
il a tout déconstruit ça et c'est très
intéressant de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne et notamment comment en
France ça fonctionne pas euh et ça c'est
un ouvrage aussi au seuil bon c'est mon
éditeur pour l'instant mais
euh formidable ouvrage qui a été traduit
par l'ancien PDG du seuil hjalon euh une
espionne au cœur de l'assassinat de GfK
euh l'inconnu de Dallas euh Marie
aversti c'est une une documentariste à
la base qui euh
euh voulait faire un un film
biographique documentaire de d'une
illustre pilote d'avion
euh qui s'appelle madame KOB j'ai plus
le nom d'ailleurs le prénom euh madame
KOB euh qui comme elle le présente euh
est en fait un un agent américain euh et
qui s'est retrouvé impliqué dans le
dossier euh donc de l'assassinat de John
FGE Kennedy c'est expliqué à partir de
toute la documentation disponible à
Washington euh suite au films notamment
de d'Oliver Stone euh sur l'assassinat
donc qui permet euh la
déclassification de tous les documents
du renseignement américain sur cette
période-là et donc elle a reconstitué
c'est impressionnant donc je spoile pas
le bouquin vous verrez ce qu' est
raconté là-dedans mais euh c'est ça
raconte plein de choses passionnantes
sur la guerre froide sur le
renseignement américain sur Cuba sur la
mafia
et et donc elle a été voilà elle a été
pas uniquement pilote d'avion elle a
fait partie des premiers programmes
astronautes de la NASA elle est pas
partie dans l'espace mais elle a été
formée par la NASA et elle a été vendue
aux États-Unis comme ça
c'est-à-dire madame KOB était connu de
la population américaine comme plein
d'autres astronautes euh et en fait
c'était une espionne américaine donc
c'était sa couverture et son nom est pas
inconnu au aux gens qui ont la
plateforme Apple
TV parce que il y a la série l'crony sur
le programme spatial
américain où il y a un de ces
personnages qui est inspiré qui est
inspiré d'elle
voilà est-ce que on pourrait avoir un
conseil pour les jeunes générations je
vais me répéter informez-vous et prenez
le pouvoir voilà comment on fait pour
prendre le
pouvoir bah ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure déjà en s'informant en utilisant
les informations et
euh en prenant la parole
voilà je te Marquand de
vel Marquand de vel merci merci à vous
[Musique]